Ah, jetzt haben wir Qualitätsoptionen.
Jetzt haben wir Qualitätsoptionen.
Ich finde das lustig, dass man
durch einfach 1-2 Mal
an- und ausschalten,
dass man Qualitätsoptionen kriegt.
Tja.
Twitch-Logik.
In 2K18.
Lull.
Huh. Nice.
Ja, Qualitätsoptionen
ist wichtig, weil wir sind in Deutschland.
Und in Deutschland
kann halt leider nicht jeder
8 Mbit
gucken.
So.
Ich bin gleich da.
Ich muss jetzt nämlich nochmal was zu trinken holen.
Dann muss ich Twitter posten und
ich mache heute mal YouTube Post. Mal gucken,
ob da noch
mehr kommen.
Mal gespannt.
Omega Lull.
Easy Clap.
Easy Cuts FPS.
E-ZF.
So.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Trinken holen.
Mal ein paar Posts. Dann geht's los.
Ich häng fest.
Ich häng fest. EZG weg.
Jetzt doch Dark Messiah.
Ja, ich finde meine Bad Company 1 DVD nicht.
Bin gleich wieder da.
So.
Jetzt bin ich am Start.
Ähm.
Weg hier.
Schon irgendein Mist eingeblendet.
Ah ja, den Text.
So.
Mir fällt gerade was ein.
Ich habe in meinem Vorschau Browser
gar keine Better Twitch TV Emotes.
Das ist ganz schöner Rotz.
Das geht ja gar nicht.
Das sieht man ja nix.
Da sehe ich kein Coggers, ja, kein Poggers,
kein Monk, äh, gar nix.
Ja, also die wichtigsten Emotes sehe ich gar nicht.
Vor allem auch keinen hier.
Das ist ja ganz schlimm.
Das muss ich gleich mal nachholen.
Wobei ich mir Franker Faces Z installiere.
Weil, finde ich besser.
Irgendwie geht es euch auch so,
dass ihr in den Menüs
von, von, von Webbrowsern
überhaupt nichts mehr findet.
Ich muss immer ewig suchen,
bis ich auf die Add-on Page komme.
Ich meine, das ist jetzt unter Chrome, muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Das ist jetzt oben, also guck mal, ne.
Wenn ich, wenn ich Chrome Add-ons aufmachen will,
da muss man auf diese komischen Punkte,
da muss man auf More Tools, da muss man auf Extensions.
Das, wenn man das nicht
oft macht, findet es doch keine Sau.
So, und jetzt mal kurz nachladen die Seite.
Jetzt sollte ich eigentlich wieder, warte mal.
Testen, jetzt sollte ich, ja, jetzt sollte ich
wieder Emotes sehen. Sehr schön.
Gut, jetzt brauchen wir bloß noch
einen Twitter-Post.
Und dann geht's los.
Poggers, beste. Poggers sind schnell.
Und, also beste Emote ist
eindeutig immer noch 0.4D.
Da haben wir uns selbst übertroffen im Stream hier,
dass wir das überhaupt kreiert haben.
Ich meine, normales 0.3D ist schon geil.
0.4D, top, das ist wirklich alles.
Spielst du noch Overwatch? Ne.
Overwatch ranked ist so
anstrengend und so tilt und
rage-anfällig.
Das halte ich nicht aus.
So, jetzt, jetzt muss ich mir mal
irgendwie, ich brauche mal eine gute YouTube
Community-Message, was ich da posten kann.
So, Twitter-Post.
Zack, Twitter-Post.
Was für eine Tastatur benutzt du?
Ähm, ich müsste
echt mal jetzt langsam mal von
Corsire, Corsare
Geld verlangen.
Die hier.
Die da, guck, da. Wobei ich
äh,
ähm,
wobei ich mir zwei
gekauft habe und, ähm,
die andere finde ich eigentlich besser, die habe ich auf der Arbeit.
Rein vom Tipp-Gefühl her. Also zum
Game ist die hier, zum Spielen ist die hier gut.
Aber, äh,
rein, also zum Tippen, so wenn man
überwiegend tippt
und auch spielt, dann würde ich mir die hier
nochmal holen. Die habe ich mir
auf die, habe ich mir eine bestellt, die habe ich auf der Arbeit
mit, mit, aber mit, ähm,
mit Numpad.
Sieht man jetzt hier nicht, da.
Die ist sehr nice.
Da fühlt sich auch die, die Knöppe
irgendwie besser an. Moin
Eiskräuter. Hast du schon
gehört, was?
Hast du schon gehört, dass der normale MP
in Black Ops 4 nur in 20 Hertz läuft,
obwohl die Beta in 60 Hertz lief? Das habe ich schon
gehört. Ich weiß
allerdings nicht so genau, warum.
Außer wenn man, dass man
die Spieler irgendwie verarschen will. Ich weiß
nicht, keine Ahnung.
So nach dem Motto
krasse Beta und dann zackt's.
Balls, alter
Sackts. 20 Hertz,
das ist, äh,
1998.
So, jetzt brauche ich mal eine ordentliche YouTube
Community Message, die ich posten kann. Was, was,
was schreiben wir da? So,
jetzt haben wir auch noch einen
YouTube Post
und dann geht's los.
Hat das Spiel jemand schon gespielt?
Kennt, kennt das jemand von euch?
Das ist auch schon ein bisschen älter, das kam, ähm,
oder so. Ich weiß noch,
ich war auf der Gamescom, als sie
das vorgestellt haben.
Auf der Games, Games Convention
hieß das ja noch, ja, 2008.
Da war ich mit dem Friseur
zusammen in Leipzig damals noch auf der
Games Convention. Da haben wir das sogar mal getestet.
Also, angespielt.
Bevor es rauskommt. Jetzt sieht man wie ewig der Scheiß schon ist.
So zehn Jahre. Kann man in
YouTube Community Messages irgendwas verlinken?
Irgendwie funktionieren die Links nicht.
Komisch.
Läuft auf Source Engine, ja, ja.
Macht es. So.
Posten wir das mal auf YouTube.
Bam. Wahrscheinlich gibt es jetzt gleich Instant
Strike von YouTube, weil die nicht wollen,
dass man auf Twitch aufmerksam macht.
Also, das Game sah im Vergleich
zu 4, ähm,
also, ne, letzten Stream
haben wir ja 4 gespielt. Das Spiel sah für
2005 extrem geil aus.
Dark Messiah of Might and Magic
sah jetzt nicht
so geil aus, als es rausgekommen
ist, ne. Ich meine, wann kam
Crysis 1 raus?
Crysis 1, guck mal.
Das kam im gleichen Jahr, genau,
das kam im gleichen Jahr wie Crysis raus.
Ungefähr sogar zur gleichen Zeit, so ungefähr.
Und,
ähm,
ja, was die, wo die auf YouTube halt Probleme
damit haben, ist, wenn man quasi ein Video
hochlädt,
nur um zu sagen, man ist live.
Das kann ja auch irgendwo nachvollziehen, ja.
So, und, ähm,
das kam im gleichen Jahr raus wie Crysis.
Und dafür sieht es echt
nicht sonderlich gut aus.
Aber das hat das niceste
Ego, ja, ähm,
Miele
Nahkampf, äh,
Stellsystem, was ich so kenne.
Das ist echt geil.
So, ähm,
legen wir mal los.
Wie gesagt, ich muss heute spätestens 22 Uhr ins Bett.
Aber das sind ja noch viereinhalb Stunden, das ist noch ein bisschen hin.
Muss mal umgehen auf die Arbeit, auch wenn ich keinen Bock hab.
Da kommen wir nicht drum herum.
Okay, auf geht's.
Ähm, Tastatur haben wir durch.
Musik machen wir mal aus.
Das Game hat ganz cool, das hat eigentlich einen ganz guten
Soundtrack.
Ähm, ich werd jetzt mal
das Intro laufen lassen und ihr müsst mir mal wieder
sagen, ob der Sound stimmt, weil wir sind ja
auf Twitch und da ist das Sound
und die Qualitätssettings jedes Mal
anders.
Wie kann ich programmieren? Ja,
kann ja nicht immer, ne.
Vor allem, ich hab da gerade so
ein paar, ähm,
Schwierigkeiten, wo ich nicht genau weiß, wie ich's machen soll.
Deswegen, da muss ich mir erst mal Offstream ein paar Gedanken
zu machen.
Mic muted, jaja, ist klar.
Ist klar.
Mein Mic ist nicht muted.
Meinst du, ich seh das nicht, oder?
Debated.
Hardcore debated.
So, ähm,
ich lass jetzt mal das Intro laufen und
wir müssen mal gucken, wie der Sound ist.
Voller Lautstärke, ja.
Also schießt mal los, klar.
Game? Äh, Moment.
Eigentlich sollte da jetzt
ein Intro laufen.
Eigentlich sollte da jetzt ein Intro laufen.
Das Game hat aber irgendwie keinen Bock gehabt.
Ja, quit?
Game? Hallo?
Äh,
okay, ähm,
was ist denn jetzt schon wieder?
Okay, äh, jetzt muss ich erst mal
das Game wieder abschießen, auch gut.
Man weiß ja nicht so genau,
was wieder da kaputt ist.
Das ist richtig MonkaS.
So, jetzt nochmal.
Ah, altes Ubisoft!
Ja, ach, ich glaub, die Lautstärke
passt so ganz gut.
Oh!
So, Leute, ich hoffe, euch ist jetzt alles klar.
Eigentlich müssen wir nach dem Intro des Games gar nichts mehr spielen, weil wir wissen jetzt eh schon Bescheid, oder?
Das Loch sah kurz so aus wie das Ubisoft-Logo.
Ja, das ist bestimmt Absicht.
Die wollen dir unterschwellig mitteilen, dass du neues Ubisoft-Zeug kaufen musst.
Ich muss mal kurz checken.
Wisst ihr, was mir bei alten Games weniger auf den Keks geht?
Dass man dich raus-tappen kann.
Ganz merkwürdig, du kannst aus alten Games nicht raus-tappen.
Und wenn man es doch macht, dann hängt es.
Guckt euch mal an, ey.
Es rumspackt.
So, ähm, war die Lautstärke okay?
Ups.
Oh ne.
Wir wurden wieder umgestellt auf indische Tastatur.
Irgendwie haben manche Games da unter Windows 10 so ein paar Pappen.
Probleme.
Dass man ganz gerne umgestellt wird auf indische Tastatur, fragt mich nicht warum.
Wahrscheinlich ist der indische Microsoft-Supporter dran schuld.
Okay, auf geht's.
Ähm, wir spielen mal auf normal.
Das Game ist auf...
Ich kann mich ja noch dunkel dran erinnern.
Das Game ist auf Hard und Hardcore teilweise sauschwer, es sei denn man klitscht rum mit Bogen und hinter einer Ecke, wo die Gegner nicht rumkommen.
Aber das ist so ein Game, was auf Hard eher nervig wird als Hard.
Master Fenrig.
Wo bist du?
Ich bin hier, Sarah.
Jetzt hör.
In der Raum vor mir ist ein Altar mit einem Spiderschwein.
Nimm es.
Wir brauchen es, um das Chantry-Kristall zu bekommen.
Ja, Tutorial-Level.
Mein Geräusch wird mich bewegen.
Und hab keine Angst.
tonight and tonight I'll be watching over you.
Ich finde es toll, wenn diese Voice Actors alle so super bedeutungsvoll sprechen müssen.
Es ist jetzt nicht möglich in einem Fantasy-Spiel normales Voice-Over zu machen.
Das muss sich alles so episch anhören.
Ja, okay. Und Taschenlampe gibt's natürlich nicht, dafür hat man Mage-Wishen oder sowas.
Easy, durchspielen.
So far, so good.
Übrigens
Übrigens, ähm
Ich hab das Game relativ oft früher durchgespielt
Bestimmt vier, fünf Mal
Ähm
Also
Ja
Halt doch mal die Klappe, ähm
Die Story ist nicht schlecht
Also
Das fängt ein bisschen, bisschen blöd an
Mein Gott, lass mich doch mal was erzählen
Ähm
Und vor allem
Kommen Dämonengrills drin vor
Dämonengrills, die den Held
Verführen wollen und
Und eigentlich
Ja, ihr seht es ja dann
Moment, ich faile gerade das Tutorial, ne
Ja
Auf, so
Ich lerne gerade zu sprinten
Wie lange streamst du schon? Fünf Minuten?
Sexy Dämonengrills, ja, ja, ja
Und kommt direkt nach dem Tutorial, die Dämonengrills
Da seht ihr das gleich schon
Source-Texturen
So
Ja, und nachdem das ein Source-Game ist
Underage, der Sebarro wieder, ja
Ne, wahrscheinlich eher so 800 Jahre alt
Also
Vollkommen in Ordnung
So, und nachdem das ein Source-Game ist
Hat man natürlich auch wieder so schöne Physik
Physik
Dinger
Und das
360-Potential ist in dem Game auch sehr hoch
Generell ist das das einzige Game seiner Art
Was ich kenne
Also natürlich, Skyrim hat auch
Ego-Perspektive, Zauberstelz
Ja, ich weiß
Ist halt Tutorial
Ja
Aber von der Dynamik her
Und mit diesem Physikkrams und so
Mir fällt kein anderes Game in der Richtung ein
Ach, C ist ducken
Kennt ihr
Verwirrt euch das auch immer, wenn manche Games
Ducken auf C legen
Anstatt auf Steuerung
Du drückst immer instinktiv
Steuerung
Und dann passiert nix
Ultraschweres Rätsel
Skyrim für Arme
Ne, hat mit Skyrim eigentlich gar nix zu tun
Es ist deutlich
Gradliniger
Dafür hat es eine rote Linie
Ah, und weil es halt Source ist
Gibt es halt schöne Physik-Stellz-Dinger
Achtung
Bäm
Schreckt
Und jetzt
Bäm
Äh
Komm jetzt hier nicht
Ah, da kommen noch mehr
Man konnte
Man konnte irgendwie auch ihm rennen, ne
Ach ne, das hab ich bestimmt noch nicht
Freigeschaltet
Du Schreckt
Das Skill
er blutet. Das ist kein Skelett, das war
ein Ghoul oder sowas.
Ade, Ade, Spam.
Da kann keiner was machen. Achtung,
der wird jetzt gerackt. Bam!
Oh, habt ihr es gesehen, wie knapp der
an den Stacheln vorbei ist?
Bam!
Man sieht schon, das Game legt
auf Physik, Physik, Physik
Krams, ich kann nicht reden, nur hauen,
Physik Krams an.
Ich wollte ihn gerade impalen, aber es hat nicht funktioniert.
Doch, jetzt.
Zack.
Das war nix.
Oh, noch so ein Team.
Das Schwert ist viel zu kurz.
Wir probieren jetzt mal was.
Komm mal her.
Treppe, Treppe, Treppe.
Bam!
Tyrannosaurus schreckt.
Noch einer.
Und Blue Bash.
Zack.
Ah.
Wie, der lebt noch?
Warte mal.
Der kriegt jetzt ne Kiste gegen den Kopf.
So.
Das war's aber.
Nur mal auf Nummer sicher zu gehen.
Nur eine Fleischwunde, ja.
Ui.
Boah, Skilp.
Yeah.
So, gleich mal specken.
Ja, Leute, wir müssen jetzt...
Aber richtig in your face, Murphy.
Wir müssen jetzt gleich am Anfang eine
wichtige Entscheidung treffen.
Das ist auch ein großer Unterschied zur 360-Version,
falls das Game immer auf der 360-Version ist.
Wenn ihr das nicht gespielt habt.
Auf der 360 gibt's fertige Klassen.
Und, also, das Game hier kam ja zuerst auf dem PC raus.
Und...
Sie waren irgendwie der Meinung, dass man es Konsolenspielern nicht zumuten kann,
ne eigenes... was zu skillen.
Deswegen gibt's auf der 360-Version vorgefertigte Skills.
Also vorgefertigte Klassen.
Und...
Hier nicht.
Das heißt, hier können wir selbst backen.
Das heißt, die Frage ist, was vermerkt ist.
Und...
Hier kann man auch so Sachen machen.
Es gibt, äh...
Grundsätzlich, glaube ich, fünf verschiedene Sachen.
Es gibt einmal...
Äh...
Also...
Schwert...
Schwertnahkampf, Zweihänder oder Schild.
Es gibt Dolche mit Stelsangriff von hinten.
Das gibt's dann hier.
Äh...
Irgendwo hier war das.
Hier, Stels.
Auf Stufe 2 kann man quasi so backstab.
Da muss man halt schleichen.
Dann gibt's Bogen.
Aber Bogen ist op...
Äh...
Bogen ist eigentlich scheiße, aber Bogen ist op, weil man sich oben hinstellen kann
und Gegner kaputt schießen.
Das spielen wir schon mal nicht.
Ähm...
Magie, Kram...
Ja, das war's eigentlich im Großen und Ganzen.
Oder so eine Mischung.
Jetzt ist die Frage natürlich, was wir specken wollen.
Specken wir auf...
Auf In-Your-Face-Gekloppe?
Specken wir auf Magie?
Oder specken wir auf Stels?
Man kann das ein bisschen kombinieren.
Äh...
Es...
Würde ich sagen, wir specken...
Ähm...
Wir...
Wir müssen auch nicht gleich specken.
Ähm...
Wir...
Wir müssen auch nicht gleich specken.
Ähm...
Wir müssen auch nicht gleich specken, ne?
Es ist nicht so...
Also...
Wir gucken mal, was...
Was lohnt sich denn?
Also...
Weiter sprinten brauchen wir auf jeden Fall.
Ohne weiter sprinten geht schon mal nix.
Weil das ist sonst viel zu nervig, wenn du überhaupt nicht richtig rennen kannst.
Also ich...
Wir specken jetzt erstmal ordentlich sprinten.
Das ist eigentlich das Wichtigste erstmal.
Aber ich würde sagen, wir specken so inzwischen, wegen wir specken ein bisschen Backstab.
Also wir specken glaube ich Dolch bis zum Backstab, dass man Gegner halt killen kann.
What now, Master Fenric?
We're done for now.
Let us hope that you will be at the end of your journey.
In your face plus stealth, genau.
This is only the first step on a long road.
Das Game...
Früher, kann ich mich noch dran erinnern, neigte das Game nach dem Intro abzustürzen.
Now, take that crystal.
You will have a newsboy to have a world away.
For today was just the beginning of my world.
Let us return home.
And I'll show you the next step in your...
Education.
Source Textures.
Source Textures an der Wand.
Das Game ist nicht gecrasht, das ist, das ist gut.
Sarah!
What?
Alter!
Game.
The fac!
Du sollst die Zwischen-Sequenz nicht überspringen?!
Was soll denn das Scheiss?
Ich hab' die Lautstärke angepasst!
Jetzt baam Zwischensequenz überspringen!
Was, was, da ist was da los?
ät.
Ja, ja, das kennen wir schon.
Das ist aber massiver MonkaS gewesen gerade.
So, aber richtig.
Speedrun-Strats.
Okay, da müssen wir uns jetzt kurz mal die 20-Sekunden-Geschwätze von Master Fenric neu anhören.
Ich drück jetzt nix.
Ich drück nix.
Oh, Story-Mode.
Das ist das Merkel-Dreieck.
Zumindest nicht ohne das.
Das Chantry-Kristall, das wir erhoben haben.
Es war unsere Schmerz, es zu erhoben, denkst du nicht?
Nimm es zu Menelag und helfe ihm, den Skal zu bekommen.
Wenn du das tust, denke ich, dass du weißt, was du nächstes Mal erwartest.
Aber, mein lieber Junge, ich werde dich nicht allein senden.
Du brauchst einen Guiden, einen Kompagnon.
Vielleicht sogar einen Guiden.
Sie kann dir vielleicht auch ein paar andere Dinge erlernen.
Was ist dein Gebet, mein Meister?
Einer kann leichter reisen als zwei, Sarah.
Bin ich, um diesen Jungen zu schützen?
Freu dich nicht, das wird ein bisschen schaden.
Halt!
By the way, my name is Xanath.
Sag doch, Demon Grylls.
Moin, iPhone.
Da ist er, Xanath.
Die freie Stadt von Stonehelm.
Crossroads von Geld und Magie.
Deliver den Kristall zu Menelag und wir können auf uns hin.
Ich hoffe es. Es war ziemlich dumm.
Wir sollten zurück in die Stadt. Wir sind in Sicht.
Der Vater wird besser.
Aber es ist unser Haus.
Es wird unser Zuhause.
Wie gesagt, das kam im gleichen Jahr raus wie Crysis.
Für einen Dahilf.
Ich halte mal die Klappe, bis das Intro vorbei ist.
Ist mehr oder weniger auf sich.
Ich glaube, Crysis kann es offensichtlich nicht mithalten für das gleiche Jahr.
Moin, Maximum Tactic.
Eier, ja, Demon, ja.
Eier, ja, wie cute, Chat.
Das ist Lord Menelag.
Hast du eine Beweise?
Das ist ein bisschen...
Ach, da reden wir.
Lass mich es sehen.
Mit einer besonderen Anmeldung von Lord Menelag.
Und da ist ein Schiff.
Lass mich dich anstecken, Stonehelm.
Wir werden dein Heim für dich bestätigen, wenn es dir gefällt.
Natürlich. Kannst du mir sagen, wo ich Menelag finden kann?
Sicher, Sir. Du gehst nach oben, über das Goldene Remedentum.
Was ist das für ein süßes Dschungelblatt?
Und hier! Sie sind wirklich hier! Was machen wir jetzt?
Bring sie weg!
Deswegen habe ich schneller Sprinten genommen, ihr erinnert euch?
Wo geht's lang?
Zack, zack, zack! Treppe rauf!
Ich bin gleich runtergekickt!
Wow!
Weg!
Piss dich!
Ich kann nicht mehr kicken, ich habe keine Endu mehr!
Äh...
An was genau bist du gerade umgefallen?
Was?
Habe ich die Wache gekickt?
Ich habe die Wache gekickt, oder?
Ich glaube...
Ich glaube, ich habe die Wache gekickt.
Alter, das ist jetzt nicht euer Ernst, oder?
Okay.
Oh ne, ich habe auch...
Okay, ich glaube, ich muss noch mal laden.
Ich muss noch mal laden.
Ich habe die Wache gekickt. Das hat das Spiel bestimmt mitgesaved.
Oh Gott, Game, ey.
Okay, zum Glück hat man...
Game.
Ah, ja.
Okay, ich mache nichts.
Wache, du machst das selbst.
Ich helfe dir nicht.
Mach das mal selbst.
So.
Hände hoch.
Mach nichts.
Lauf dich selbst mit dem Viech.
Oh, direkt.
Ich war es nicht, dass du umgekippt bist.
Ich habe dich nicht gekickt.
Okay.
Ah, jetzt geht es weiter.
Oh!
Irgendjemand hat gefragt, ob das Game auch später not safe for work wird.
Das dauert noch eine ganze Weile.
Das kriegen wir wahrscheinlich heute nicht hin.
Wird es aber. Zumindest ein bisschen.
Aber nicht wirklich.
Aber not safe for work auf jeden Fall.
Aber das dauert bestimmt noch fünf Stunden oder so.
Jetzt darf ich auf die Wachen schießen.
Das ist jetzt vollkommen in Ordnung.
Einer nicht raus. Nein.
Kann man zoomen? Darf ich zoomen?
Oh nein, vorbei.
Schreckt.
So.
Jetzt ins Auge.
Jawoll.
You did it.
I'd hug you if I could.
Tausend Nachts Ski reicht ganz knapp.
Aber mal richtig in your face.
Massiv in your face.
Wobei in your eye
sowas gibt es glaube ich nicht.
Hat noch keiner gesagt bisher.
Ich kann mir das so richtig vorstellen.
Der nächste Gears of War sagen sie nicht mehr in your face sondern in your eye.
Und dann haben sie es in der deutschen Version
wieder übersetzt mit in dein Auge.
Genau so wie sie es auch übersetzt haben in Gears of War.
Und dann haben sie es in der deutschen Version wieder übersetzt mit in dein Auge.
In Halo war das.
Wo sie dann die deutschen Sprecher sagen lassen haben,
zur Hölle.
Ja, in dein Gesicht.
Oder war das doch Gears of War?
Ich weiß nicht mehr.
Ah, eine Foodration.
Sollte ich nicht eine Waffe haben?
ich nicht eine Waffe haben?
Ich sollte eine Waffe haben, oder?
Oder nicht?
Sollte ich nicht eine Waffe haben?
Moment.
Ich bilde mir ein, ich sollte eine Waffe...
Ne, anscheinend noch nicht.
Okay. Dann müssen wir die Kiste
leider kaputt treten.
Move dich, Wache.
Ähm.
Jetzt potion.
Nichts drin.
So, und danach müssen wir uns
unbedingt überlegen, was wir specken.
Dieses Raytracing ist der Wahnsinn.
Ey, das Spiel sah für seine Zeit gar nicht so schlecht aus.
Ich mein, Source Engine Games 2008
waren jetzt nicht absolut der Gipfel
oder so, ja.
Aber schon ganz okay.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Staff. Also Stabkampf
in dem Game, das weiß ich von früher noch,
ist der letzte Kack. Sack total.
Oh, ein Bow.
Baubeste. Haben wir Pfeile?
30 Pfeile. Sehr schön.
Haben wir vielleicht noch ein Schwert
oder so für mich?
Ja. Was ordentliches.
Und danach müssen wir uns
überlegen, was wir specken.
Schild.
Daggers.
Nice.
Da sieht doch keiner, dass da ein Schwert
liegt. Schwert.
Äh, was ist Inventar?
Inf? Ah, hier. Tab.
So, umsortieren. Den komischen Stab, den braucht kein Mensch.
Die können wir eigentlich gleich wieder kicken.
Ähm, Bogen da.
Health Potion machen wir irgendwo hier hinten hin.
Schild hier.
So. Darkvision brauch ich eh kaum.
Machen wir da hin.
Okay. Gut.
So, passt.
Safe.
Ich glaube, ich specke jetzt mal das erste, dass ich ein Schild
nehmen kann. Weil einfach nur
Schwert ist ziemlich doof.
Aber wir können auch
Daggerstellen machen. Geht auch.
So. Was sind meine
Objectives?
Entrance zum
Haus vom Obermage finden.
Das Juggt kein...
Oh.
Ich mach nix. Ich mach nix. Alles gut.
Alles gut. Ich mach nix.
Ganz ruhig.
Das ist auch in...
RPG ist immer geil, dass man
in alle Häuser reinrennen kann und
keinen juckt so wirklich.
Lea auch am Start.
You know what they say about the size of a man?
Man's front gate.
That big one must be manalags.
Ich mag das Demon Grill.
Ach ja, übrigens, ne?
Es bleibt nicht nur beim Demon Grill.
Diese Zauberin, die ihr da gerade gesehen habt.
Ich muss mal gucken, ob es hier noch irgendwas zu looten gibt.
Wie gesagt, ich kenn die Story ja schon.
Ich kann mich zwar nicht mehr so richtig dran erinnern, aber so grob.
Die Zauberin ist auch scharf auf den Held.
Die da eben gestanden hat.
Das heißt, man muss sich irgendwann im Laufe des Games
entscheiden, ob man Demon Grill
oder Zauberin haben will.
Was geht?
Gibt's hier irgendwie...
Ups.
Alles gut.
Ich mach noch ein paar Sachen kaputt.
Ja, ja, ist gut.
Ich will nicht, dass die Wachen,
dass die Wachen sauer werden, weil es ist Game Instant Lose.
Instant verloren.
Wo ging's raus? Da ging's raus.
Gucken wir mal, ob es in dem Haus irgendwas zu looten gibt.
Äh, hier waren wir schon.
Gucken wir mal, ob wir noch hier irgendwie...
...man hier noch irgendwo rein kann.
Weil ein paar Held-Potions sind schon nicht verkehrt.
Wieso denn entscheiden,
weil die Story das so möchte?
So viel kann ich sagen.
Was genau ist blöd, weil das ist
Major Plot Point.
Mana-Drank.
So, haben wir sonst irgendwas?
Scroll or Freeze.
Alles overrated Magic-Krams.
Moment, hier unten waren wir schon, ne?
Gut.
Gehen wir raus.
Was?
Oh, war das anstrengend.
Nee, hier ist der Keller, ne?
Wo?
Alles gut.
Ich war's.
Ola.
Ist hier irgendwo weiter?
Hier waren wir schon.
Okay, gehen wir zur Quest.
Gehen wir zur Main Quest.
Oh, da oben ist was.
Seht ihr's?
Seht ihr's? Da.
Da ist was.
Das, was leuchtet, sind immer irgendwelche
Tunic-Items.
Oder Special-Items.
Kommt man da irgendwie rein?
Dann gehen wir auch gleich zur Main Quest.
Oh.
Hier kommt man noch nicht rein.
Nope.
Keine Chance.
Rare Loot.
Ja, es geht so.
Es ist kein Diablo mit Loot her,
aber es gibt...
Es gibt im Endeffekt für jede Klasse
ein paar Rüstungen und ein paar...
ein paar Robben und ein paar Stelzdinger und Zeug.
Was geht?
Excuse me.
Oh.
Du musst der Anwalt sein.
Hier ist unser Gast.
Oh Gott.
Äh...
Okay.
Ich bin hier, um Lord Menelag zu sehen.
Auf behalf von Meister Fenric.
Du musst Saris sein.
Ich habe mich über dich überrascht.
Vielleicht für keinen Grund.
Unser Onkel hat gesagt, du würdest uns Cyclops töten.
Entschuldigung.
Ich bin Lyanna.
Menelags Schwester und Puppe.
Niece.
Puppe.
Hm.
Der Onkel wird sehr glücklich sein, dich zu sehen.
Aber du willst vor dem Abend waschen.
Bitte, folge mir.
Mit Leidenschaft.
Ich meine, ja.
Exzellent.
Gar!
Wir hatten eine Feier vorbereitet, in deiner Ehre, Armin.
Der Rock ist unglücklich geschnitten, muss ich mal kurz sagen, ne?
Das sind halt Source-Engine-Gesichter.
Das konnten sie damals schon ganz gut.
Willkommen im Haus von Menelag.
Man, der Rock ist schon sehr unglücklich, irgendwie, ne?
Also, du bist Saris.
Schön, dich zu sehen, Junge.
Mit diesen Necromancern bei den Kriegen.
Guck dir das an.
Ich habe mich überrascht.
Ich vertraue dir, dass du das Chantiri-Kristall mitgebracht hast.
Das Spiel läuft auf 144 FPS.
Ich nehme das, mein Junge.
Für die Sicherheit.
Morgen sehen wir uns.
Und vorsichtig mit dieser Suppe da.
Auf dem tiefen Isle,
auf dem Rücken der Schatten.
Lass Arantir seine Armee gegen die Wälder schießen.
Wir werden seine Schuld abdecken.
Verzeih Arantir nicht zu leicht.
Es gibt Gerüchte, dass er der dunkle Messias sein wird.
Oh, was für Nonsens, Mädchen.
Alle drei von uns wissen besser als das.
Aber der Zeitpunkt ist richtig für die Prophezeiung.
Ich werde mich um die schmutzigen alten Prophezeiungen kümmern.
Du wirst dich um die Expedition kümmern.
Du bist es in der Hand.
Natürlich, Onkel.
Gute Nacht.
Und du auch.
Und du auch, Sarah.
Bitte sag mir nicht, dass du das so süß findest.
Hör auf, Junge.
Ich weiß, warum du wirklich hier bist.
Aber Lyanna nicht.
Und wir werden es so bleiben.
Fenrigs Geschäft trifft sie nicht.
Verstanden?
Wovon redest du?
Hm.
Vielleicht weißt du es nicht.
Und das ist wahrscheinlich für das Beste.
Die Servanten werden dir das Gästehaus zeigen.
Hör auf zu schlafen, Hero.
Wir fahren mit der Morgenwelle.
WAS?
Irgendwie Muss ich jedesmal, wenn einer sagt BOY...
Er geht sofort.
Äh, nicht geht sofort.
Girl-of-War!
Denken.
Ich werde sehen, ob der Meister in Ordnung ist.
Benutze dich!
Warum sollte ich mich heilen?
Ich werde die Monster bashen.
Bleib hier!
Miss!
Schreckt!
Da fliegt er.
Wied er steht wieder auf?
Na, der steht immer auf.
So, Schwert haben wir schon.
Mal gucken, ob hier oben noch irgendwas drin ist.
Staggers. Haben wir schon?
Geht das auf?
Hallo? Geht das auf?
Nope.
Ich erinnere mich. Irgendwo war hier ein Secret.
Da kann ich mich noch dunkel dran erinnern.
Es gab irgendwie am Anfang des Games ein Secret,
wo man richtig coole Waffe gekriegt hat.
Wenn man an
irgendeine Lampe oder sowas gedrückt hat.
Ich weiß aber nicht mehr genau, wo das gewesen ist.
Schreckt.
Jetzt kann ich euch gleich mal die coole Physik
Sachen in dem Game zeigen.
Äh, Staff Sack, das wollen wir nicht.
Food Ration.
Ne, das war glaube ich noch ein Stückchen weiter.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob der Stream
ist nicht in 30 FPS, oder?
Das war G-Bait.
Stimmt's?
Guckt mal nach, bitte.
Ich kann gerade nicht nachgucken,
weil ich gerade nicht auf dem zweiten Bildschirm kann.
Der Stream müsste
1080p, 840 FPS sein.
Was?
30?
Hm.
Da muss ich jetzt doch mal gucken, was da los ist.
Da muss ich mal kurz schauen,
auf dem zweiten Rechner.
Sollte eigentlich 48 sein.
Das ist jetzt der Mega-G-Bait
gerade von euch.
Ich kann gar irgendwie nicht auf den zweiten Bildschirm.
Warum nicht?
Jetzt. Hä?
So, alles gut.
Was erzählt ihr?
Alles gut.
Kompletter G-Bait wieder.
Ja gut, auf dem iPhone
keine Ahnung.
Das kann ich nicht so sagen, aber
ihr müsst dann auf dem PC 48 FPS,
eigentlich könnt ihr auch 60 FPS das nächste Mal machen.
Mein 8 Mbit ist genug, upload.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns mal die coole Half-Life,
ähm, nicht Half-Life,
die Source-Engine-Physik-Geschichten an,
die man machen kann.
Und danach müssen wir specken.
Ich meine, guckt mal, wir haben 6 Skill-Points.
Also entweder, ihr könnt es euch ja mal überlegen,
nach dem Fall specken,
ihr könnt es euch ja mal überlegen, was wir machen wollen.
Also, entweder gehen wir hier Richtung,
Richtung Stelz.
Da müssen wir aber gleich direkt,
da müssen wir warten und müssen direkt in
Sneak-Attacks specken.
Mit Dolch.
Oder wir gehen erstmal
auf, ähm,
also auf Magic habe ich keinen Bock.
Oder wir gehen erstmal auf Melee-Kombat,
inklusive den neuen Attacks.
Also sprich, dass wir, ähm,
einen ordentlichen Charge kriegen,
dass man ein Schild nehmen kann,
und sowas in der Richtung.
Das, ihr könnt es euch ja mal überlegen,
was wir machen wollen.
Ob wir, ob wir quasi die, die Dagger-Stelz-Geschichte
machen wollen, oder die, äh,
Schwert-Schild-In-Your-Face-Geschichte.
Wobei die nicht exklusiv ist.
Das eine profitiert auch vom anderen, ja.
Hätte ich jetzt Sneak-Attack,
könnte ich den Typ halt von hinten, von hinten wegstelzen.
Was ich halt so nicht kann.
Reckt.
Guck, man kann halt auch
hier so...
Man kann den halt auch
auf die Kisten gegen den Kopf hauen.
Weil halt Source-Engine-Physik-Kram.
Was halt übelst
Bock macht in dem Game.
Was ich so auch noch in keinem anderen
Game gesehen hab.
Da ist er down.
Bam.
So, jetzt müssen wir mal gucken,
ob hier noch irgendwo ein bisschen
Loot drin ist.
Warte, da ist noch einer.
Achtung, Feuer, Feuer.
Ich will hier mal ins Feuer treten.
Komm mal her, komm mal her, her, komm, her, komm,
her, komm, her, komm, her, komm.
Ja, komm, ja, komm.
Komm her.
Ja, okay.
Äh, fast.
Fast.
Das sah jetzt zwar nicht so elegant aus,
aber es hat prinzipiell funktioniert.
Das Feuer ist...
Das Feuer ist schuld, genau.
Okay, dann specken wir mal die Voraussetzung
für Stelz.
Das ist nämlich ganz cool, wenn man
stehen bleibt, dass man
Sequels angezeigt kriegt. Das ist ganz praktisch.
Daher kommt auch dieses
dieses Geklingel, was man im Hintergrund hört.
Okay, aber hier gibt es ansonsten nichts mehr.
Boom.
Biegschack.
Okay, dann specken wir jetzt mal...
Also,
wir brauchen eh insgesamt 6 Skillpoints,
um
Stelz-Attack
skillen zu können.
Und nachdem wir wahrscheinlich keinen
einzelnen Skillpunkt kriegen,
specken wir jetzt erstmal,
das hier für Power-Attack.
Das geht nämlich auch mit Dolchen.
Also sprich, ähm...
Also sprich, das hier ist nicht nur für Schwert und Schild.
Ich kann jetzt zwar ein Schild nehmen,
auf dem nächsten Punkt, aber
man kann sich jetzt, man kann jetzt quasi den
den Angriff chargen.
Sowas hier in der Richtung.
Und das geht mit Dolchen...
Mit Dolchen geht das im Endeffekt auch.
Also da profitiert alles von.
So, und das heißt, beim nächsten,
bei den nächsten 2 Skillpoints specken wir
äh, Sleek-Attack-Speck.
Oh, you!
Bäm!
Au!
Ach ja, übrigens,
eine Sache, die ich auch am Anfang,
kann ich mich noch dran erinnern,
des Games nie gecheckt hab, ist,
dieser Kreis in der Mitte, ne,
da zeigt an, wie gut man gestelzt ist.
Man sieht nämlich, wenn man hier im Schatten ist,
ist da der Kreis fast voll.
Und wenn man hier im Licht ist, dann ist der Kreis halt,
ne, dann ist der, ist der weg.
Also das in der Mitte ist quasi
unser Stelz-Indikator.
Wenn ich das jetzt breake,
äh, oh, wir schießen mal mit dem
Bogen drauf.
Bogen in your face, Bogen im Kopf.
Konnte man nicht zoomen, irgendwie?
Man konnte doch zoomen.
Wartet mal.
Controls, äh,
Bow-Zoom-R
hab ich doch gedrückt.
Es könnte natürlich auch sein, dass mein Bow
einfach keinen Zoom hat.
Oder dass die englische Tastatur rumspackt.
Oder die indische,
oder was auch immer gerade eingestellt ist.
Ich glaube, der Billigbogen hat einfach
keinen Zoom.
Ja.
Ne, das Ding hat einfach keinen Zoom.
Das ist einfach so da.
Guck mal, auch wieder,
was für ein, was für ein Idle-Sway, äh,
wie soll man damit treffen?
Ups.
Das war kein Headshot.
Bam.
Oh, der ist schon down.
Schreckt.
Jetzt ist er down.
So, äh, gucken wir mal, ob hier im Garten
irgendwas drin ist.
Also, die Kampfmittel,
die Mechanik ist halt superflüssig und macht
übelst Bock.
Bam.
Also, der steht nicht mehr auf.
War das mal einer aus dem Fischer?
Den Zoom muss man skillen.
Ja, so war das. Okay.
Ja, so gut kann ich mich dann immer dran erinnern.
Don't forget, you can kick your enemies in fire.
Würde ich machen, wenn ich noch ein Enemy hätte.
Kletter Sounds.
Keep looking.
We need to get inside and secure the crystal.
Dicht.
Sammeln hier Mana-Trank, Hells-Trank, nix drin.
Nö.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wo das war, es war, irgendwo gab es so ein richtig geiles Item
am Anfang.
Das ist, das ist mein Schlafzimmer, hier komm ich her.
Gut.
Gehen wir hier hinten weiter.
Loading.
Nicht crashen.
Nice.
Ist nicht gecrashed.
Okay.
Ja.
Good Job.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich jetzt Krach machen soll hier drin.
Haben wir anscheinend keiner gehört.
Werfen wir mal eine Schaufel, falls Gegner da sind.
Warum wackelt das so?
Ja, immersion.
Ah Fuck.
Alter.
Kannst mal...
Der hat durchgehackt.
Habt ihr das gesehen?
das gesehen? Der hat einfach durchgehackt.
Ist hier irgendwas drin?
Ah, das Zeug kann man anzünden, weil man
Feuerpfeile hat später.
Ich erinnere mich noch.
Wo?
Oh, die kicken wir jetzt irgendwo rein.
Oh.
Zack.
Reckt.
Au.
Das sieht aber ungesund aus.
Ich hänge.
So.
Ähm.
War das hier, wo man...
Oho.
Oh.
Äh.
Was auch immer.
Was ist hier drin?
Äh.
Spoda.
Spodas.
Ah, platt gemacht.
Ups.
Ich wollte das Ding ja gar nicht kicken.
Au.
Falle.
Na geil.
Jetzt habe ich eine Potion, die mir volles Hells gibt.
Ich kann das gleich reinhauen, weil mich die Falle geownt hat.
Ganz, ganz grandios.
Timing.
Übrigens an Weihnachten.
Na.
Also.
Ich habe den ganzen Dezember Urlaub.
Das heißt, da werden wir wahrscheinlich fast jeden Tag streben.
Stellt euch das mal vor.
Sachen gibt's, hä?
Okay.
Hier geht's lang.
Psch.
Von hier kommen wir.
Das heißt, wir können jetzt da rum, oder?
Oh, da brennt was.
Bogey.
Bogey muss zuerst dran glauben.
Zack.
Diese Slow-Motion machen.
Gibt es hier irgendwas?
Irgendwas zu looten?
Loot.
Loot, please.
Nein, kein Loot.
Oh.
Oh, stärkere Gegner.
Ich muss mal kurz...
Ich will nicht irgendwo dagegen hauen, dass die mich hören.
Nelson.
Oh.
Bam.
Rekt.
Oh.
Noch mehr.
Oh, die weichen ja auch aus.
Ich muss weg.
Panzer am Start.
Ja, richtig.
Achtung.
Und.
Bam.
Oh, komm.
Lauf rein.
Ja, ja.
Ist gut.
Lauf rein.
Lauft rein.
Hui.
Jeder hat keinen Bock reinzulaufen.
Nehmen wir mal wieder das normale Schwert.
Oh, schön.
Geil vorbeigehauen, ne?
Uh.
Kopf ab.
So.
Oh, jetzt aber.
Es sind viel mehr Wachen da, als ich das in Erinnerung habe.
Ist das For Honor auf Low Quality?
Äh.
Ich finde, das hat überhaupt keine Ähnlichkeit mit For Honor.
Fängt schon mal an, dass es nicht peer-to-peer gehostet ist.
Macht mir das Ding eigentlich Damage?
Das muss ich mal kurz ausprobieren.
Oh.
Okay, das macht mir Damage.
Was ist das für eine dünne Kreatur, die die Wand hochgelaufen ist?
Ja, man weiß es noch nicht.
Man weiß es noch nicht.
Das hat uns die Story bis jetzt noch nicht erzählt.
Oh.
Monka essen.
Eigentlich wollte ich die Truhe öffnen.
Elf Potion.
Zu, zu.
Hopp.
Dein Schild habe ich schon.
Alle Schilde sind ja nicht so geil.
Hier geht's nicht lang.
Hat der vielleicht eine Wache, einen Schlüssel oder so?
Ne.
Ne, sieht nicht so aus.
Kein Schlüssel.
Das wird normalerweise auch angezeigt.
Auch nicht.
Äh.
Ah, doch.
Die letzte Tür ist es natürlich.
Logisch, ne?
Immer die letzte Tür.
Den müssen wir rushen.
Wir können ihn auch versuchen zu out-bogeyn.
Na, meinst du es trifft den Kopf so?
Ach du Scheiße.
Okay.
Meine Bogenskills halten sich in Grenzen.
Wo ist er?
Game? Crash!
Yeah!
Nice Game.
Gut gemacht.
Stabile Games in 2K18.
Kann man noch irgendwas runterstellen?
Also Anti-Lasing lassen wir auf jeden Fall an.
Nö, eigentlich kann man da nichts mehr runterstellen.
Ich hab schon keinen...
Ich hab schon keine AF drinne.
Das Game hat ein bisschen ein Problem auf modernen Rechnern.
Also, beziehungsweise das Problem hat es jetzt auch auf älteren Rechnern.
Das ist irgendwie ein 32-Bit-Game und die haben Probleme mit über 2 Gigabyte.
Also sprich, sobald ihr Game mehr als 2 Gigabyte rankraben will, crasht's.
Das heißt, man muss selbst auf dem Super-High-End-System das ein bisschen runterstellen.
Okay, gucken wir mal, ob wir ihn jetzt out-bogeyn können.
Jawoll!
In your face!
Was ist denn jetzt los?
Achso, weil da unten Leichen sind.
Kommen sogar Mücken.
Nicht übel.
Immersion.
Auf und ein Down.
Also die Immersion ist extrem hoch.
Wenn sogar Mücken kommen nach 2 Minuten.
Oh, den hat's ganz schön getackert.
Fast wie ein 4 mit dem Nadelwerfer.
Zack, zack.
Kick.
Kann zwar umfallen.
Oh, da kommt der Nächste.
Oh, zack.
Moment, der lebt noch.
Das geht nur mit Dolchen, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung hab.
Was haben wir hier?
Aha.
Ja, guck mal da.
Ein Seil.
Nope.
Was haben wir hier oben?
Gibt's hier was Gutes?
Did I hear something?
What was that?
Gibt's hier irgendwas Gutes?
Hier ist doch überhaupt nichts, oder?
Wow.
Wie kommt der hier hin?
Komm her.
Kick.
Flieg runter.
Der fliegt nicht runter.
Alter, kannst du?
Okay, der hat keinen Bock runter zu fliegen.
Jetzt.
Oh.
Jetzt aber.
Guck mal.
Oh.
Hier kommt man roads Engine.
Jeap.
Alright.
Mal.
Hier kommt man sonst nicht dahinter, oder?
Uhuhuu.
Geh weg.
Nast.
So gibt's hier sonst noch irgendwas zu looten?
Ich würd mal sagen nee.
Hier, das Level ist vorbei.
Ups.
Ja, wir haben noch ein paar Pfeile, ein paar Bogen.
Naja, nichts.
Gehen wir raus.
Oh, hier geht's rein, oder?
Ach ne, hier kamen wir über die Dämpfer irgendwo hin.
Vergesst Stopps.
Für Neder profiter.
Mach, mach вот hier.
Ah.
Und ja, das wieder leaders появen.
Jetzt müssen wir quickly's co Nyoooooo
Das ist, weil man hier irgendwie schon Sneak Attack und Gedöns gespeckt hat.
Oh, Secret Mana Potions.
Die keiner braucht, weil ich keine Spells habe.
Jawoll.
Yeah.
Äh.
Griechen?
Also nicht die aus Odyssey?
Ja.
Äh.
Okay, Moment.
Wo müssen wir einschlagen?
Ah, Moment.
Jetzt bin ich hier an der...
Ah, verstehe.
Hier, das ist hier, wo ich...
Oh, fuck.
Hier bin ich doch eben hochgegangen.
Auf.
Hoch und dann gehen wir da weiter, wo die komische Wache gewesen ist.
Oh, nice.
Level vorbei.
Das Game sieht interessant aus.
Das ging an dir vorbei.
Ne, das Game ist von 2008.
Also, Siti, ich...
Ich weiß ja nicht, wie...
Wann du schon spielst, aber vielleicht...
Hattest du das einfach nicht auf dem Radar, weil das vor deiner Zeit war.
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung, Achtung.
Was?
Das hört sich schon unangenehm an, oder?
Oh.
Bottle of Juice.
The Juice.
Huh?
XQC könnte das bestimmt gut erklären, was The Juice ist.
Weil, muss ich ehrlich sagen, ich gucke eigentlich so relativ selten Overwatch-Geschichten.
Ich hab mir das so überguckt.
Guck mal, das Ding schwingt immer noch.
Das haben wir gefühlt vor einer halben Stunde angehauen und es schwingt immer noch.
Just so you know, dear.
Menelag is expendable.
The crystal isn't.
What do you mean?
The crystal was for Menelag.
Oh, da blinkt was.
Das blinkt da.
Wie soll ich denn da hinkommen?
Das sieht nicht so aus, als möchte das Game,
dass ich da schon hinne komme, oder?
Ne.
Rein, rein, rein, rein.
Oh.
So, wir haben noch keinen Sneak Attack, ne?
Keinen Sneak Attack.
Wir können...
Ne, wir haben auch nicht genug Skillpunkte für Sneak Attack.
Das heißt, uns bleibt im Prinzip nichts anderes übrig, wie...
In your face!
Oh!
Ah!
The fuck?
Da bin ich, richtig.
Und du aber nicht mehr lang.
Zack.
Bam.
Rekt.
Die machen nix mehr.
So, erstmal gucken, ob's hier noch schön Loot gibt.
Loot. Was haben wir denn hier?
Öl. Brauchen wir nicht.
Ziemlich coole Mechanik.
Ja, ja, das ist nice.
Es fällt kein anderes Game ein in dieser Richtung.
Und man kann's halt auch nicht wirklich mit Skyrim vergleichen,
einfach weil's Ego-Kampf hat.
Ist komplett anders, ne?
Also, wahrscheinlich werden das die...
Wie soll ich sagen?
Die, die Skyrim gespielt haben.
Im Prinzip hat wahrscheinlich außer mir jeder Skyrim gespielt.
Ähm, zumindest.
Mehr als fünf Minuten.
Ähm, bestätigen können, dass das nicht viel mit Skyrim gemein hat.
Vom Kampf her.
Aha.
Was ist hier?
Schlafzimmer.
Mana-Pots, nee, Health-Pots.
Haben wir hier irgendwas drinne?
Noch mehr Mana-Pots, die man nicht braucht.
Auch nix.
Nix.
Ja, hast du.
Ähm, ich sollte mich mal heilen.
Hm.
Ich sollte mich mal heilen.
Futter, Futter, Futter, Futter.
Social Eating.
Stream.
Vielleicht die Banane aufheben.
Geht's nicht weiter.
Okay, das Game möchte von uns, dass wir hier lang gehen.
Rein da.
Perfekt.
Ist er down, der krasse Mage.
Oh.
Crystal, oh nein, Sarath, du musst diesen Ghoul folgen.
Wir können uns später treffen.
Wir können skillen.
Ähm.
Ja.
Soll ich den jetzt verfolgen oder skillen?
Ähm.
Verfolgen.
Alter, Game, was ist los?
Was ist dein Problem, Game?
Tch, tch, tch, tch, tch.
Alter, das Game.
Das, das mein Meme-Bot macht.
Das Game kaputt, glaube ich, habe ich das Gefühl.
Kann das sein?
Tch, tch, tch.
Schneller.
Kletter.
Verfolgungsmission.
Und ich wette mit euch, in der Verfolgungsmission, ich kann ihn gar nicht fangen.
Ich kann ihn.
Selbst wenn ich will, kann ich ihn nicht fangen.
Fable Lost Chapters.
Das habe ich nicht gespielt.
Äh.
Wo geht's lang?
Ja, das sehe ich auch.
Äh, kannst du mal reinklettern?
Äh.
Ach da.
Zack, zack, zack.
Ich kann nicht hinterher.
Ich habe kein Endo mehr.
Wie kann man Fable nicht gespielt haben?
Ach, du hast vorhin gesehen, ich habe ganz viele Sachen nicht gespielt.
Jump across, you can do it.
I've...
Perhaps that foul thing took the high road.
There's no time.
We have to get through this.
There.
Woah.
Careful.
Rennen.
Ja, ja, man kann das Ding nicht treffen.
Das ist so eine typische Verfolgungsmission, die man nicht gewinnen darf.
Was geht?
Ich muss weg.
Nee, aber Fable ging echt an mir vorbei.
Kommt möglicherweise noch mal ein Video zu World War 3.
Oh, hier muss man ran.
Okay.
Ja, wenn ich es endlich mal gespielt habe.
Ich wollte es ja am Samstag oder so schon spielen, als es rauskommt.
Jetzt haben wir aber den Server down.
Au.
Wo geht es lang?
Hier.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Huh.
Monka Kiga.
Careful, man.
Puh.
Source Engine Physik-Rätsel.
Kann auch einfach drüber laufen.
Hier.
Geschafft.
Nice.
Ja, ja, World War 3 ist draußen.
Ähm, ich habe es beim Lost ein bisschen geguckt.
Der Eindruck, dass es ein Battlefield-Abklatsch ist, ähm, also im positiven Sinn hat sich nicht bestätigt.
Das Game spielt sich wohl eine ganze Ecke langsamer als Battlefield.
Also es scheint doch ein bisschen was eigenständiges zu sein.
Infiltrate the Warehouse.
Jawoll.
Oh, Skillpunkt.
Leute, jetzt wird geskillt.
Jetzt muss gespeckt werden.
Das war eine nice Verfolgung, ja.
Okay, Sneak Attack, ne?
Stell es, Leute.
Leute.
Warte mal.
Stell Speck.
Wir können Stells...
Wir haben neun Skillpunkte.
Das heißt, wir können Stells specken und den zweiten Angriff hier.
Oh, das ist cool.
Da waren wir das doch.
Stells Archer.
Bogengraben ist in dem Game übelst OP.
Also, an sich...
Ich zeige es euch mal.
An sich ist Bogengraben schlecht.
Problem ist halt, du kannst dich halt an sowas wie hier stellen und alle Gegner outen, wo sie nicht hochkommen.
Moment.
Der Dude hat mich gesehen.
Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Ich kann ja nicht gesehen haben.
Okay, specken wir.
Also, specken wir das Stells.
Stells Nummer zwei.
Dann haben wir Sneak Attack.
Und wir specken Mele Combat für Schild.
Dann können wir nämlich Schild ausrüsten.
Und mit Dagger können wir schön wegstellsen.
Wo ist denn der Typ hin?
Achtung, jetzt Stells Stream.
Wo ist er denn?
Eben war er doch noch da.
Hallo.
Ich gehe jetzt mal in die andere Richtung und gucke, was da so ist.
Closed.
Pilze.
Ah, ein Hintereingang.
Verstehe.
Aber was Hintereingang ist, ist unsinnig.
Wir wollen keinen Hintereingang.
Wir sind zwar ein Stells, aber wir sind ein Offensive-Stellz.
Also, sprich wir...
Stellsen uns zu den...
Oh, fuck, es geht ja gar nicht auf.
Dann machen wir das vielleicht doch nicht jetzt.
Wie soll man da hinstellsen?
Ich werde doch mal durch den Hintereingang gehen.
Übrigens, achtet mal drauf, ne.
Das ist ein Game, wo man stellsen kann, ohne dass es Stellsindikator, Minimap, Versteck, Gefahrenanzeige und sonst was gibt.
Hier muss man auch auf gut Glück stellsen, dass das funktioniert.
Oh, wir sind hier mitten im Gegengebiet.
Oh, jetzt kommt eine krasse Stellse in Aktion.
Du kannst mich überhaupt nicht hören.
Du kannst mich nicht hören.
Das ist per Definition unmöglich, mich zu hören.
So, wie Sneak Attacken wir die Dudes denn jetzt am besten?
Du bist sicher, dass es geschlossen ist?
Die Ghouls werden unsere Treppen haben, oder wenn es nicht so ist.
Hey, es ist sicher.
Hör auf.
Wie Sneak Attacken wir die jetzt am besten?
Ah, den da oben Sneak Attacken wir jetzt.
Der will schon richtig von uns Sneak Attacked werden.
Oh, fuck.
Das müssen wir nochmal machen.
Ich will den Sneak Attacken.
Ich will den richtig, richtig dolchen.
Wie machen wir das jetzt?
Sneak Attack.
Einmal will ich Sneak Attacken, wenn ich jetzt schon gespeckt habe.
Ich gehe mal wieder in Schatten.
Jetzt.
Oh, Mann.
Alter, was soll das denn?
Stellst die Sau weg?
Ja, mache ich.
Mache ich.
Alter, stellst dich.
Wie stellst dich jetzt sowas von weg?
Wo ist er?
Was?
Alter.
Ha, gestelzt.
Omega, stellst du Deck?
Da oben ist Loot.
Alter, wie die mich sehen.
Wie die mich sehen.
Egal.
Egal, genug gestelzt.
Tja.
Die können ja auch nichts.
Wie?
Der Typ hat es überlebt?
Stopp, es geht los.
Jetzt aber.
Zack.
Achtung, der.
Das lassen wir jetzt noch einstürzen.
Oh, schön drauf.
Auf.
Kiste.
Kopf.
Das sind aber ganz schön viele.
Wie man ausweicht.
Ha, wie ist das denn geflogen gerade, habt ihr das gesehen, das Messer?
Lol.
Die machen Damage.
Die machen echt krass Damage.
Hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Hallo, Schild.
Müssen wir gleich wieder was futtern und Healthpacks reinhauen.
Oh, der wird erstelzt jetzt.
Dum, du dum, du dum, du dum, du dum, du dum, du dum, du dum.
Und...
Stellst du Deck?
Pfff.
Jawoll.
Oh, was ist das denn?
Ein Longbow und ein Stelzergrab.
Bringt das plus Armor.
Sehr nice.
Teller.
Braucht dann sowas.
The Juice brauchen wir.
So, jetzt gehen wir in das Warehouse und weiter geht's.
Oh, war da was?
War das, war das?
Ach ne, das ist die Tonne.
Ich muss euch mal was fragen.
Ähm.
Ich hab's...
Ja, letztens zu ihm schon mal versucht.
Irgendwie anzusprechen.
Aber irgendwie ist mir dann was dazwischen gekommen.
Was guckt ihr denn eigentlich für Let's Player?
Oder hab ich das letzten Stream schon erzählt?
Hä?
Was ist denn das hier?
Weil, ich hab das Problem, ich würd mir manchmal ganz gern ein paar Spiele angucken.
Und halt nicht unbedingt selbst spielen.
Aber irgendwie...
Mich nerven die meisten Let's Player.
Außer Dance Game.
Das ist der einzige, den ich mir angucken kann.
Von dem kann ich mir im Prinzip fast alles angucken.
Aber wahrscheinlich...
Weiß nicht, wahrscheinlich weil das so in meinem Alter ist, irgendwie.
Oder was heißt Dance Game?
Dance Gaming.
Das ist der einzige, den ich mir angucken kann.
Schon lange eigentlich.
Und eigentlich nur ihn.
Ansonsten...
Kaum.
Kronk kann ich mir nicht angucken, das liegt aber nicht an Kronk, sondern...
Weil die, ähm...
Let's Player ist relativ...
Weil die im Prinzip mir zu langsam sind.
So nach dem Motto, wir brauchen fürs erste Level fünf Tage, das drehe ich durch.
Hier oben hat eben was geklitzert, ne?
Hey, das funktioniert!
Nice.
Source Engine FTW.
Was haben wir denn hier zu bieten?
Stone Skin, Full Health Potion und Ring of the Phoenix.
You found a magic ring.
Once your health reaches zero, the ring prevents...
Okay.
Alles klar.
Das ist nice.
Weil sie einmal plus eins leben.
So, mehr gibt es hier glaube ich nicht.
Oh, was ist das da?
Ja, wie gesagt, ich gucke bei Kronk die Let's Plays nicht, weil ich Kronk nicht gucken will, sondern einfach weil es mir zu langsam ist.
Ansonsten ist er mir von deutschen Let's Playern, quasi erst von denen, die ich kenne, von seiner Art her noch am liebsten, aber das geht mir einfach zu langsam.
Oh, wir haben skill-points.
Das glaube ich dir sofort.
Demon grills.
So sind sie.
Eine Forge.
Oh, kann ich jetzt forchen?
Oh, nice.
Nice, Leute, wir forchen jetzt.
Wir lassen die Wachen mal da rumlaufen.
Ist egal.
Jetzt wird geforcht.
Zack.
Äh, nein.
Hammer.
Ah, pusten.
Blown.
Krasse Crafting Action hier.
Hier ist es geschmolzen, yo.
Oh, diese Immersion, Leute.
Ich sag's euch, diese Immersion.
Plate is not hot enough.
Okay.
Ist das jetzt fertig?
Was ist das?
Sword Hills.
Ein langen Schwert, nice.
Uh.
Ha, jetzt sind wir super equipped.
Jetzt wird geschreckt.
Zu Zeiten, wo die Sword Hills
in Source Engine angesagt war,
hatten ganz viele Spiele so kleine Physik-Rätselchen und so.
So was gibt's aktuell gar nicht, ne?
Plate's not hot.
Nice joke.
Der ist gut.
Ich will nämlich nicht an denen vorbeischleichen.
Ich will die bashen.
Vor allem, jetzt hab ich ein neues Schwert, ne?
Ring of Arcane.
Ups.
Ich hab rausgetappt.
Inventory of Tap ist auch ganz schön beknackt.
Äh.
Na.
Zehn Mana.
Lull-Mana.
Wer bitte braucht Mana?
Oh.
Money.
Was ist da los?
Muss ich nachgucken.
Ich hab gehört, dass einer donatet hat.
Ähm.
Zwei Euro für das geile Game und deine Stimme von It's Adi.
Dankeschön.
Ja, irgendwann bin ich auch mal Twitch-Partner.
Ich weiß, ich sag's schon seit,
seit irgendwie einem Dreivierteljahr oder so.
Äh, komm ich dir nicht her?
Doch.
Fallout.
Ja, ja, das ist...
Ich mag aber Inventar auf Tap nicht.
Warum kann man Inventar nicht einfach auf I machen,
so wie das alle machen, ne?
In dem, in dem Game ist es halt besonders schlimm,
weil Schleichen ist halt...
Die haben, haben die mich gesehen?
Ach, das ist die Spinne.
Die machen die Musik wegen der Spinne an.
Ernsthaft.
Du, du, du, du, du, du, Achtung, eine kleine Spinne kommt angekrabbelt.
Das ist Bodo.
Bodo.
Ohohohoho.
Noch mehr Spodos.
Einfach drüberlaufen, auch gut.
Ich will die, ich will die Gegner nicht umlaufen.
Wartet, Leute.
So, Leute, ich muss nochmal zu, ich will die Gegner bashen.
Warum soll ich denn die...
Warum alles in der Welt sollte ich denn die Gegner umlaufen?
Ha?
Warum sollte ich das denn machen?
Ich hab mir ein neues Schwert geforscht.
Und mit dem neuen Schwert muss natürlich,
muss natürlich die Gegner jetzt gebasht werden.
Warum, warum, warum sollte ich die Gegner denn umlaufen wollen?
Warum sollte ich die Gegner denn umlaufen wollen?
Weil?
Weh.
Das ist ja total bescheuert.
Siehste?
Neue Schwert am Start.
Instant Gegner gebasht.
So muss das sein.
Guck' mal, außerdem verpass ich so viele Türen und so viel Loot.
Ring of Weapon Master.
2% Chance Critical Health.
Ich bleib mal hier auf meinen...
Chain, nice!
Chainmail, Endurance won!
Ähm, Endurance?
Endurance?
Wo ist Endurance?
Endu?
Wo kann man Endu specken?
Also, Chainmail wäre schon sehr, sehr nice, ja.
Oh, noch ein neues Schwert.
Wäre ja immer besser.
Critical Hit, eins.
Plus drei Damage.
Nehmen wir mal ein langes Schwert, hat schon plus drei Damage.
Das brauche ich nicht.
Sonst so irgendwas?
Nope.
Ähm.
Hier komme ich her.
Oh, noch eine Tür.
Noch mehr Loot bestimmt.
Loot.
Eine Note.
Jaja.
Tell me more, please.
Ein nicer Dagger.
Der braucht, stell's drei.
Stell's drei habe ich ewig nicht.
Da brauche ich zehn Skillpunkte für.
Das wird nix.
Okay, weiter geht's.
Siehste?
Warum hätte ich die Gegner umlaufen sollen?
Richtig dumm.
Ah, Gachi Emo's.
Alle, alle habe ich.
Habe es alle am Start.
Ich habe mir extra bei der Twitch-TV Premium gekauft.
Wegen der Spielmechanik wäre Half-Life 2...
Na, viele Source-Games haben so ein bisschen Physik-Kram, aber...
Achtung, wir machen es jetzt so.
Wir werfen es dem gegen den Kopf.
Und den anderen, den anderen, wenn der herkommt...
Komm her.
Der hat gerade seinen Kollege plattge...
Bist du dumm?
Junge, bist du dumm?
Was ist mit dem los?
Hat er mich nicht gesehen, oder was?
Oh, ist der blöd.
Ist der blöd.
Oh, Mann.
Ja, ganz bestimmt.
For sure, for sure.
Mach mal.
Achtung.
Ich stelle es dich jetzt.
Bam.
Und für den Swag.
Das Spiel bietet echt einen Haufen Möglichkeiten.
Jaja, es gibt kein anderes Game, was mir einfällt in diese Richtung.
Das verstehe ich gar nicht, weil das ist schon...
Das ist quasi so der...
Heutzutage würde das Game nicht mehr Dark Messiah of Might and Magic heißen,
sondern heute würde es irgendwie...
Ähm...
Keine Ahnung.
Kill Simulator oder sowas heißen.
Übrigens auch noch so ein Ding, was viele Games damals hatten, eine Konsole.
Heute wird es Kill Simulator heißen.
Weil sich Simulatoren ja heute super verkaufen.
So, jetzt sind wir hier, wo wir oben rausgekommen wären sonst.
Leute, ich muss mal kurz was gucken.
Äh...
F5?
Wie sie sich alle drüber lustig machen, dass ich mich verschrieben habe in meinem YouTube-Post.
Da ist auch sowas.
Auf Rechtschreibfehler springen alle immer super an.
Eigentlich müsste man Rechtschreibfehler absichtlich reinmachen,
weil man will, dass Leute sich nicht verletzen.
Weil man will, dass Leute reagieren.
Pay attention when you open the cells. Villagers keep trying to escape.
Wer hätte das gedacht, dass Gefangenen versuchen zu entkommen, wenn man die Zellentür öffnet?
Ernsthaft?
Da kann man nicht drauf kommen.
Is that him?
Yes, that's Arantir.
Don't make a sound.
His power is beyond anything you've ever seen.
Look at that, look!
He's opening a portal between the Necromancer Hive and the tunnels here.
My God!
That is rare power.
There are more ghouls, I think, for the final assault.
I must remember that.
Okay.
Ich muss ihn ablenken.
Ja schrei nicht so rum, halt die Klappe!
Halt die Klappe?
What can you do to draw their attention?
Gute, ich mach die Zellentür auf, ne?
Pull the lever!
Sad.
To you, Asha.
The eight-headed, we offer our lives...
Ah, es ist halt Source Engine.
Das merkt man gleich.
Without a solution.
Ich finde auch Source-Engine-Games sehen heute immer noch gut aus.
Dank ihm hier.
Ich habe nur gerade in meinen Vorschauen gesehen, dass ich immer Meme-Tool und Gaben drin habe.
So, jetzt, hä?
Let's get out of here before anyone notices.
Weggestellt.
What a marvelous performance, my dear.
Wie er immer schnauft.
Ich finde es in Fantasy-Games immer geil, dass die Bösen so richtig doof sind, ja?
Oh, mehr Demon-Grill.
He and I have certain shared...
...allegances.
Right now he's looking for an artifact called the Skull of Shadows.
For reasons of his own that are doomed to fail.
He thinks you're going to help him, the fool.
At least not without this.
The Shantary-Crystal that we retrieved.
However, boy, I don't trust you out there alone.
I need someone to hold your leaf.
One can travel lighter than two, Sarah.
Don't worry.
You'll learn to enjoy the pain.
You can call me Xana.
Alter.
Ich wusste doch, dass er auf Demon-Grill kommt.
Sarah, wach auf.
Leicht da.
Was ist passiert?
Xana?
Was ist los?
Wer?
Was bist du wirklich?
Das Traum war nur ein Necromancer-Kurs.
Glaub es dir nicht, mein Lieber.
Ich bin ein Freund.
Ein Alli.
Es könnte noch mehr sein.
Die haben sie gut gewoist.
Also, die hat eine gute Voice-Actress.
Das kauft man da richtig ab.
Das ist Demon-Grill.
Sarath?
Glaub, Elath, du bist sicher.
Ich war so überrascht über dich.
Du hast bestimmt viel durchgegangen.
Hast du den Crystal gefunden?
Bitte, sag ihr nein, um nur ihre Reaktion zu sehen.
Ja, ich habe ihn zurückgebracht.
Wunderbar.
Außer, dass jetzt die Necromancer unser Schiff genommen haben.
Wir können nicht auf die Insel kommen.
Wenn nur mein Onkel hier wäre.
Warte, Sarath, könntest du das machen?
Aufsteigen und den Gang aufbauen?
Dann könnten meine Männer ihn aufbauen.
Wir würden ihn direkt von Erintere aussteigen.
Ich werde es umsetzen.
Bereit sein, wenn das Gang-Plank runtergeht.
Lass mich das einfach bewegen.
Oh, so entscheidend.
Ich versuche jemanden zu beeindrucken.
Oh, so entscheidend. Ich versuche jemanden zu beeindrucken.
канале
Oh Gott, jetzt muss ich musst du dich punks exert und kämpfen.
Jetzt muss ich deineemo稽 abholen, denn der kleine Arsch ist noch ohne Verbindung und der Thanks mientras nach einem kuriosz me жьу
arqugang
Wer hätte einées
hardened
Kacke. Und nachdem es in dem Game keinen Shop
gibt, lassen wir die
einfach liegen.
Schiff.
Boah!
Alter!
Ist ja gut.
Regt euch ab. Ich will nicht gleich eskalieren.
Nicht gleich eskalieren, Leute.
Da kommt was.
Ha! Null.
Noob.
Direkt.
Ah, verstehe.
Easy Mode.
Äh.
Hä?
Bewegt sich das nicht?
Doch, jetzt.
Hat rumgebackt.
Ja, es ist witzig, dass Wachen direkt sterben, wenn es ins Wasser kommt, ne?
So dachte ich immer noch, oh mein Gott!
Ich bin nass! Bam!
Instant Death.
Hahaha.
Oh.
Careful now.
These are tight quarters for fighting in.
Boah!
Hohohoho!
Oh, da liegt noch ein Kopf.
Schreckte.
Ich hab da oben genau was gehört.
Also, da können wir nicht raus.
Da können wir nicht raus.
Wenn die da oben rumlaufen.
Ach, die...
Der Typ ist natürlich so doof und geht die Leiter runter.
Da kann ich ihn schön wegstelzen.
Achtung, Achtung.
Stelzetext!
Oh, das hat er gehört.
Hat er das gehört?
Den stelzen wir jetzt auch.
Der Stelzetext!
Ein Key.
It's not nice to go through other people's things.
Birds of a feather, aren't we?
Gib Rips.
Gut, dass wir ein Stelzetext gespeckt haben.
Mana brauche ich nicht.
Ich find's cool, ne?
Es kriegt in diesem Schiff keiner mit,
wenn ich hier wahnsinnig Krach mache beim Kisten zerlegen.
Das ist egal.
Aber dreh dich auf das falsche Holz.
Da kommen sofort alle Wachen an.
Oh nein, da war jemand.
Aber, just RPG things.
Äh.
Wo geht's weiter?
Ach, da.
Null.
Okay, uff.
Oh, Loot.
Den haben wir schon, diesen komischen Ring.
Brauchen wir nicht nochmal.
Catch Dells.
Food Rations.
Ja, futtern wir mal was, dass wir ein bisschen Hells kriegen.
Was haben wir eigentlich für, für Elixiere?
Hells, Portions, 10 Hells.
Okay.
Wir haben einen Magic Mushroom,
der kompletten Hells und Mana wieder aufbringt.
Das ist natürlich auch sehr nah.
Nice.
Oh, pscht, pscht.
Stell's tag.
The last words of the prophecy of the demon Messiah
are coming true as we speak.
10 centuries and that is all.
So said he whose name we dare not speak.
We are fortunate that Lord Arantir is prepared to play his part
as it has been foreordained.
May the mother of silence bless our works
and guide our hands...
Jetzt müssen wir, müssen wir stelzen.
Mach nicht so einen Krach.
Be here.
So, wie stelzen wir die jetzt am besten?
Die scheinen sich nicht zu bewegen.
Kann man die hochklettern vielleicht?
Max, was hast du eigentlich nach der Ausbildung gemacht?
Also Weiterbildung ETC.
Ich habe erstmal da weitergearbeitet, wo ich die Ausbildung gemacht habe.
Ich glaube,
zwei oder drei Jahre und dann bin ich woanders hin.
Wollte ich... Ah, nice, nice, nice.
Der kommt runter, da kann er erst stelzt werden.
Achtung, Stelz-Attack.
Stelz-Attack.
Bäm.
Das hat er nicht gehört, oder was?
Ein Hook.
Taugt ihm.
Alter, das...
Warum Inventar?
Warum Inventar auf Tap?
Ob das was taugt?
Das hört er bestimmt nicht, wenn man hier alles kaputt schlägt.
Doch.
Wow.
Der Hook ist nice.
Der Hook regelt.
Sonst gibt es hier nichts mehr.
Halt die Klappe.
Schrei nicht so.
Warum?
Wenn ich stelzen will?
Oh.
Ich muss weg.
Stelz.
Oh, Stelz-Attack.
Wisst ihr was?
Scheiß auf Stelz.
Ein Key.
Damit kann ich die Goblins aufschließen, ha?
Oder auch nicht.
Wie kann man die Goblins aufmachen?
Aha.
Lasst mich in Ruhe.
Ich habe euch befreit.
Oh, der wird geschreckt von denen jetzt.
Will der mich jetzt bashen?
Alter, was soll das?
Was soll das, ne?
Werden sie befreit und schon wenden sie sich gleich gegen den, der es befreit hat.
Das ist auch Goblin-Logik.
Aber der Hook geht ab, oder?
Kommst du her?
Weggehookt.
Alter, was ist los?
Kann man den Hook eigentlich mit Schild verwenden?
Oh.
Das ist fast wie Roadhog.
Ah, zumachen kann man nicht mehr.
Und hier hätte man wahrscheinlich auch noch was bashen können.
Oh.
Einfach etwas bashen können.
Das haben sie schon nice gemacht.
Hier haben wir wirklich viele Möglichkeiten.
Scrolls.
Mal kurz was futtern.
Bisschen Hells.
Nice.
Okay, sonst ist hier nichts mehr drin.
Hier noch was.
Nope.
Wisst ihr, was ich ganz cool finde an so Games von früher?
Also das eine, was mir gerade auffällt, ist wieder dass sie einfach...
Ah, super.
Das haben wir.
uns das jetzt haben wir uns das gerade schön gecraftet und jetzt gibt es hier
alles drauf ich finde lineare games haben auch ihren vorzug ja jetzt nix
gegen open world games an sich aber games mit einem roten faden sind auch
nicht schlecht immer unsere solche aber wir doch stealth attack machen
müssen wie hast du mich gesehen alle wie hat er mich gesehen die tür ist zu
ja ist klar kann man dann auch durch die tür killen das geht natürlich nicht wie
der lebt noch aber nicht verlangen okay gibt schwert
ja mit dem schwert geht das gleiche
viel besser
ordentliche waffe eigentlich wollte ich stellten aber die gegner haben irgendwie
strich durch die rechnung gemacht was das denn ein elfenbogen plus zwei
critical hits habe ich nicht sagt kann man den irgendwie kopf abhauen
nicht wirklich
skill tonnes könnte schon mal überlegen was als nächstes becken kommen hier in
die mitte eagle mit ist noch nicht jetzt verschlossen
da müsste doch irgendeine wache jetzt gehen wir weiter scheiße auf laut das
bisschen
order finden wir irgendwie einen weg hier Badrach bestimmt irgendeine wache
schlüsselmann wie quasi ein guter waller rechts einen weggestellten stück fünf
stunden normalścikt
aber heute er cotton mann might say a
kommen wir hier rein? Ich meine, die Tür ist...
Die Tür ist
dicht.
Wache? Schlüssel?
Nope. Hier ist auch dicht.
Ach komm, scheiß drauf.
Ein paar Kisten da.
Wozu?
Oder checkt irgendjemand,
wie man da reinkommt?
Ah, vielleicht hier rum?
Ne, hier
sind wir gespawnt.
Die Wache hat auch nichts dabei gehabt.
Schlüssel?
Ah!
Nice!
Ah! Easy.
Mal kurz ein bisschen geguckt.
Sehr schön.
Looten.
Looten-Beste.
Ein nice Loot.
Was haben wir hier?
Scrolls, die keiner braucht.
Mana-Dränke, die keiner braucht.
Schinken, den man braucht.
Und nochmal einen Mana-Drank, den keiner braucht.
Und hier haben wir...
Hier sind wir gespawnt.
Oder? Ist das unser Spawnraum?
Ja, das ist unser Spawnraum.
Okay, das hat es jetzt nicht so gebracht.
Not-Rekt, Rekt,
Really-Rekt, Getsch-Rekt,
Tyrannosaurus-Rekt.
Tyrannosaurus-Rekt ist für mich auch
die beste Rekt-Abwandlung, die es so gibt.
Ne, hier lang.
Was haben wir denn so?
Kann man hier irgendwas drehen?
Oh, wir müssen
Stelz-Mode-Activate.
Oh, es ruckelt.
Ich kann mich gerade erinnern, das hat auch damals
auf meinem Rechner geruckelt.
Schiff-Level ist anscheinend nicht...
Oh ne, jetzt hat er mich gesehen.
Ich wollte ihn doch gerade erstelzen.
Come on, bruh.
Bruh!
Was ist da los?
Lass das nicht so lange andauern wie Half-Life.
Hast du die letzten Streams geguckt?
Es wird am Stück...
Durchgespielt. Okay, das werden wir heute nicht schaffen
am Stück. So viel kann ich sagen.
Achtung, die werden jetzt erstelzt.
Stelz-Attack.
Okay, wird doch nicht erstelzt.
Moment, Moment, lass mich weg.
Wo ist der Hook?
Steam-Overlay.
Hook. Bam!
Bam!
Nächster. Bam!
Haha!
Rekt, Alter!
Da ist er.
Positioning ist alles.
Der Hook, äh, der Hook
raucht uns alle.
Ich mag das Demon Grill.
Und die Sprecherin ist auch gut.
Die bringen das echt gut rüber.
Warum geht es hier nicht auf?
Ich will hier rein.
Lasst mich rein.
Wort von gestern ist auch schon verfügbar.
Sehr nice.
Sibaro ist wieder on point.
Hier darf ich hochklettern, aber weiter nicht.
Weiter ist nicht erlaubt.
Geht es hier irgendwo rein?
War hier unten noch eine Tür?
Was muss ich denn machen?
Ich muss die Brücke runter machen.
Wo ist denn die Brücke?
Hier?
Ach da!
Das ist voll offensichtlich.
Wie sieht das mit dem Haken schon leicht lächerlich aus, oder?
Aber der Haken ist nice.
Stylish ist er natürlich schon mit dem langen Schwert.
Das Wizard-Grill ist auch am Start.
Oh.
Äh, Mr. Milchmann, das ist so.
Oh, Gegner.
Ich muss an die Ballistas.
Lass mich rein.
Ballista-Bash.
Jeder.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, jeder Shooter.
Das ist ja kein Shooter.
Jedes Spiel aus Ego-Perspektive braucht eine...
braucht mindestens eine Einlage mit automatischen Geschützen.
Wenn man jetzt treffen würde, wäre das natürlich auch ganz nice.
Oh, rekt.
Die hat es zerrissen.
Oh, die hat es auch zerrissen.
Bisschen mehr Foff könnte ich gebrauchen.
Oh, die zerreißt es auch.
Bisschen mehr Foff wäre nicht verkehrt.
Alter, die Bogis ownen die komplett.
Oh, wie er wegfetzt.
Die Bogis ownen die komplett.
Was ist hier los?
Hat die sich gerade geheilt?
Kann das sein?
Und die treffen auch gut.
Mache dich nicht.
Achtung, gleich kommt er hier.
Bam
Oh fuck.
Ich dachte, man kann zoomen oder so.
Kann man aber nicht.
Da fliegt er.
Auch easy.
Ich dachte ...
Das hätte auch ein bisschen gehen können.
Das war doch ganz lustig.
Ich bilde mir ein, Leute.
Es gab ja auf dem Schiff noch Crafting-Material.
Das habe ich noch so im Hinterkopf.
Man konnte später richtig Krustanten Teil nehmen.
Waffe craften und das Crafting-Material war irgendwo hier auf dem Schiff, aber ich
habe keine Ahnung mehr wo. Vielleicht weiß das ja noch einer von euch, der das
gespielt hat. Ansonsten werden wir ohne auskommen müssen.
Was für Spiele spielst du noch und wie lange geht der Stream? Ja, also der Stream
bis spätestens 22 Uhr, da muss ich pennen. Was für sonst noch zu spielen, kann ich dir
erzählen. Die zwei Grills mögen sich.
Natürlich. Ja, aber was wir sonst noch so spielen, mal hier kurz zwischen
eingeworfen. Ich habe mir nämlich eine Liste gemacht
mit allen Sachen, die mir so eingefallen sind, die in Frage kommen. Da haben wir
zum Beispiel Bad Company 1 Kampagne, Titanfall 2,
Battlefield 3. Also es geht mir immer um den Singleplayer. Also Kampagne, Let's Play
ich stelle es. Battlefield 3, Battlefield 4, CoD 4, 5, MW2, Black Ops 1, Back
Ops The Line, Soldier of Fortune 2, Dark Messiah 4, 4 hatten wir
gestern. Far Cry 1, Far Cry 3, Crysis 1, Max Payne 1 und 2, Shadow Warrior, Bioshock, Dishonored, Dead Space 1, nur 1. Black Mesa,
Half-Life 2, Metro Stalker
und Dark Project.
Oder das Remake, mal gucken.
Ja, das heißt, wir sind
für die nächsten 10 Jahre beschäftigt.
Ungefähr, oder?
Oh!
Da ist ein Loch.
Diesen Ring habe ich jetzt schon 3 Mal, ne?
Kann man Titanic machen?
Ne, kann man nicht.
Na, dann gehen wir mal zu Lea rein.
Wie heißt sie eigentlich genau?
Leana.
Lassen wir uns mal erzählen,
was Leana Wichtiges mit uns zu besprechen hat.
Leana Wichtiges mit uns zu besprechen hat.
Ja, Leute.
Was sagt ihr?
Wizard Grill oder Demon Grill?
Ich persönlich
bin ja für Demon Grill.
Alter, Chad, reißt euch mal zusammen.
Why not?
Warum nicht beide, weil das nicht geht.
Spider-Man.
Oh!
What?
Zum Glück alles nur Traum.
Das ist die Insel der Tempelung.
Ja.
Ja, Sir.
Der Rock,
der ist wirklich unglücklich geschnitten.
Der Rock, der ist wirklich unglücklich geschnitten.
Ja.
Hoffentlich können wir sie vermeiden. Sie sind sehr schützend für das Tempel.
Kommt, lasst uns gehen!
Serath, schnell!
Dieser Mann ist verletzt. Schau ihn dir an!
Was, Meelaine?
Was ist hier passiert?
Orks kamen aus dem Tempel.
Sie fuhren uns raus und blockierten die Entfernung.
Einige Männer sind immer noch verletzt.
Sie sagten, sie sahen...
Geh' aus meinem Weg!
Paukai.
Paukai? Er ist auch verletzend.
Bitte helfe, Serath. Sie werden weiter kämpfen.
Was ist ein Paukai?
Ein degenerates Drogon.
Aber sie leben nicht in einem Raum.
Wir müssen uns helfen, wenn sie es tun.
Kommt!
Wir müssen diese Orks entfernen!
Krieger!
Hüter!
Die Spiegel-Gottin hat gesprochen!
Diese Drogen und Dämonen-Freunde müssen nicht als erstes verletzt werden!
Erinnern Sie sich an unsere Orks!
Unsere Angehörigen!
Für den Plan!
Für das Blut!
Wir werden sie verletzen!
Übung
Der Seraph.
Satz 3
Wie einen変 arrestierte 6-Punkte.
Schreckt!
Orks.
Was können Orks schon?
Nix.
Nix können Orks.
Guckt es euch an.
Noob-Orks.
Guckt.
Wo ist der nächste Ork?
Moment, Leute.
Ich schlage mal.
Den hätten wir schön stealth killen können.
Deswegen ist gar nicht...
Wir sind ja quasi gerade split-specked.
Wir können ja stealth und Mele machen.
What?
Stealth-Attack hat nicht funktioniert.
Das ist schlecht, wenn Stealth-Attack nicht funktioniert.
Der Ork da oben sieht ein bisschen geclitcht aus.
Alter, Ork macht Damage.
Ork macht richtig gut Damage.
Der Ring hat uns gehealt.
Jetzt aber.
Flop.
Geclitchte Orks auch down.
Wir können sie auch hooken, die Orks.
Roadhog-Style.
Ein Orkschwert.
Und ein Orkschild.
Nice.
Taugt das Orkschild was?
Naja, das sagt.
Strength 2.
Ein Skillpunkt fehlt uns noch.
Ein Skillpunkt fehlt uns noch für das Orkschwert.
Warten wir mal.
Oh, da oben.
Oh, Ding.
Den Counter-Bogen gehen wir jetzt.
Au.
Alter, ich bin kein guter Bogenschütze.
Nein, das wird nix.
Hook.
Weghooken.
Was ist das?
Scroll.
Bashen.
Hooken.
Bam.
Und Bam.
Au.
Hand ab.
Oh, mehr.
Mehr Orks.
Ich hol mal ein Schwert raus.
Triple Orks.
Attacke.
Oh.
Vorbei.
Oh, Bam.
Nice.
Schreckt.
Ich hab ihn entwaffnet.
Okay.
Er reißt.
Wusste gar nicht, dass es geht.
Zack.
Der holt seine Waffe.
Ne, ne, ne.
Du holst nicht deine Waffe.
Doch, du holst seine Waffe.
Oh.
Die Orks.
Alter, die Orks gehen ab.
Die Orks wollen es echt wissen.
Oh.
Nice.
Okay.
Jetzt können wir Strang's Becken.
Waren wir das doch?
Ne, wir können nicht Strang's Becken.
Oh, wir müssen erstmal diesen Kack hier specken.
Scheiße.
Hoch.
Das hat mich aber erschreckt.
Das ist hier.
Das war typisch Gryll.
Wirft das hier um und fragt mich, ob ich verrückt bin.
So war es aber auch.
Okay.
I know you try and shadows become almost invisible.
You can also pickpocket your enemies.
Ne, das ist scheiße.
Das ist zu viel Stelz.
Ich brauch Stelz für Sneak Attack und ansonsten nix.
Wir specken Melekombat.
Und, ähm.
Ähm.
Strength.
Okay, wir können leider nur.
Uns fehlen vier Skill Points, dass wir das Org-Schwert nehmen können.
Entweder specken wir Strength 1 oder wir specken Endu 1.
Dann können wir nämlich gleich die Kettenrüstung anziehen.
Leute, was sagt ihr?
Kettenrüstung oder Spahn auf Org-Schwert?
Also, im Prinzip ist jetzt die Auswahl zwischen mehr Rüstung und mehr Stil.
Oder mehr Damage.
Damage.
Hells.
Yes.
Ja, was?
Yes ist keine valide Antwort.
Was wollt ihr?
A oder B?
Ja.
Dann zauber mal auf.
Oh, Tunnel.
Tunnel-Stelz.
Cool.
Also, cheesy, Bro.
Spoders.
Viele Spoders.
Spoder, Woodface.
Oh, was ist das?
Alter, was ist das?
Fliegen denn hinten Fische?
Ach, wir haben jetzt ja Overhead-Strike am Stahl.
Jawohl.
Woodface.
Was ist das hier?
Strafe-Action.
Strafe ist...
...stark in mir.
Hells.
Da oder da?
Oh, boah.
Stimmt.
Stimmt, das gab's ja auch.
Das hab ich ja schon ganz vergessen.
Das Ding ist übelst nice.
Noch mehr Physik-Stelz.
In dem Game.
Guck, ich zeig's euch mal.
Gucken, wo was ist, wo man Bogen-Stelz machen kann.
Hier.
Also, wenn man mit dem Ding gegen Holz schießt,
dann gibt's ein Seil.
Was sehr, sehr nice ist.
Oh.
Secret?
Lol, Secret.
Ich dachte, hier geht's lang.
Omega-Lul.
O-M-G-I-G-A-L-U-L.
Es wird mal Zeit, dass irgendwie einer den Omega-Lul-Song macht.
Ich mein, den Kappa-Song gibt's ja schon.
Ah, da oben.
Äh.
Das ist nicht wie Pfeile fliegen.
Ah ja, so fliegen Pfeile.
Das ist okay.
Okay.
Äh.
Hab ich Item übersehen?
Ach nee, ich muss da dran ziehen.
Oh.
Monk Hass.
Rein. Jawoll.
Abfackeln.
Oh, die Orks, die wurden richtig geschreckt gerade.
Tür zu.
Was passiert eigentlich?
Nix.
Sieht nur ungesund aus.
Ich sag doch, Skyrim kann einpacken, Leute.
Oh, mehr Orkse.
Wollen wir die, wir versuchen die Orke, Orks zu stelzen.
Oh, das sind zu viele Orks.
Lea.
Stehen bleiben.
Wir locken den jetzt an.
Und jetzt.
Bäm.
Machen.
Damage.
Ich mein.
Lea muss schon denken, dass der Held der übelst geile, äh, Checker ist, ne?
Verkloppt allein als Zauberlehrling fünf Orks.
Eats.
Vor allem Eats AF werden ihn verhauen, ja?
Ist ja nicht so, dass er damit Probleme gehabt hätte.
Schaufel.
Oh.
Ups.
Pff.
Okay, Lea möchte keine Schaufel gegen's Bein haben.
Lass die Schaufel hier.
I'm glad you made it, Duncan, when so many of our men didn't.
The fighter with us is Sari, Fenric's apprentice.
He saved our mission twice already in stone.
Hm.
Then I'm doubly glad that he is here.
A worthy sword arm is always welcome.
He's very worthy, Duncan.
Don't we have a skull to find here?
But enough chappels.
Aaron, you'll be on our heels.
Hm.
Other boats, Duncan?
Will you descend the boat?
Cancel the climb, Scott?
You may have to retreat, Lea.
Hm.
Nee, als ob du Dark Messiah spielst.
Tja, siehste?
Haha.
Hm.
Huh.
Mach ich.
Hm.
Mache ich.
Das Game ist geil.
Ich hab das, ich hab das schon vier, fünf Mal durchgespielt, also vor Ewigkeiten.
Ich hab das, ich hab das schon vier, fünf Mal durchgespielt, also vor Ewigkeiten, ja.
Max wird zum Let's-Play so.
Also in letzter Zeit irgendwie schon, ja.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was da los ist.
Ring of Regeneration.
Regeneration.
I think we need to get up there to get out.
Ja.
Rope Bow.
Zack.
Don't forget that nice bow you found before.
Oh, krasser Schwinger.
Die ist schon scharf auf den Held.
Noch mehr Orks.
Ich bin mal gespannt, was ein Ork macht,
wenn ich ihn anschieße von hier.
Oh.
Ja, was machst du jetzt, Ork?
Was machst du jetzt?
Was machst du jetzt, Ork?
Hä?
Was machst du jetzt?
Ich bin hier, Ork.
Den hat's zerrissen.
Rekt.
So langsam läuft's.
Haben wir genug?
Haben wir noch Punkte für, für, äh, ne, zwei, zwei fehlen uns noch für Orkschwert.
Ja, auf.
Hi, Simon, 1, 2, 4, 4, 2, 1, 6.
Beste.
Das ist eine Worte für es.
Der Onkel hat gesagt, dass die Skala der Schatten in der Krypte außerhalb dieses Geräts ist.
Wenn du den Kristall in den Herzen des Tempels befestigen kannst, kann ich ihn öffnen.
Aber es wird Zeit nehmen.
Es gibt hier alle Art von magischen Befehlen.
Das Korridor führt in die Klammer, wo du den Kristall aktivieren kannst.
Machen wir.
Die Inkantation wird viel Zeit für die Präparation nehmen.
Vielleicht noch ein bisschen hältst du, oder?
Ich werde dich nicht mehr allein machen.
Wirst du hier sicher sein?
Ich wäre sicherer mit dir, aber ich muss den Spell vorbereiten.
Hör auf.
Es tut ja schon weh.
Oh, ist ein kleines Mischmädchen, der Angst vor der Dunkelheit hat.
Ich mag es nicht, sie alleine mit Orken zu verbringen.
Oder Aranthir.
Ich brauche sie, um innen zu kommen.
Du bist so ein Gentleman.
Willst du schon?
Demogrill.
Demogrill versus Grille.
So.
Wie charmant.
Es gibt eine Eintracht, die einen Goblin hat.
Alter, ein Crips-Sub.
Was die hier für Leute haben.
Oh.
Äh.
Das müssen wir nochmal machen.
Das müssen wir nochmal machen mit der Säule, die den Goblin erschlägt.
Ah.
Blah.
Was?
Willst du mich rollen?
WTF?
Warum ist er nicht gestorben davon?
Lul
Ui
Ich sag euch, Weihnachten wird übelst geil
Oh
Ich wollte jetzt eigentlich sagen, warum
Ja, also ich meine
Weihnachten, Dezember wird übelst geil
Axt
Mir fehlt da so ein Schlüssel
Ähm, weil
Da hab ich
Einen ganzen Monat bin ich da
Einen ganzen Monat bin ich am Start
Der wird wahrscheinlich fast täglich gestreamt, so hat im Dezember
Wie kommt man da hin?
Muss man vielleicht doch
Das Zeug hier anschießen
Ah
Oder was bringt mir das jetzt genau?
Okay, was, was, äh
Komm ich da jetzt irgendwie drauf?
Aha
Das ist jetzt ja nice
Was gibt's denn hier?
Zeug, was ich nicht brauche, aber trotzdem cool gefunden zu haben
Hihihi
Okay, zurück muss ich noch nicht gehen
Ach, können wir noch ein
Schwert forschen?
Ah
Das kenn ich noch
Alter
Huh
Da konnte ich mich noch dran erinnern
Sonst wär ich jetzt hier direkt instant
Instant wipe, instant verreckt
Wonka ist
Ah
Irgendwie hab ich mich da grad wieder dran erinnert, dass ich das gleiche
Vor 10 Jahren schon mal hatte, wenn die drinnen abgekratzt wird
What?
The fuck?
Was zum, was war das?
Äh, what?
Game, please
Ich würd sagen der Damage Trigger ist an der Wand
Von dem Ding, ich muss warten bis das Rope
Nicht mehr wackelt
Okay, jetzt warten wir
Eieieiei
Moin, Quau, was?
Kaul
Kappe
So, jetzt darf ich aber runter, oder?
Ja
No, that was almost a painful death
Try to avoid doing that again
Will you, my sweet?
Now
Woah
Gut, dass ich ein Schild dabei hab, hä?
See you
Da haben wir doch das richtige geskillt
Ne, jetzt nicht weiter
Oh nein, ist ein anderes Schild, wie ist denn das Ork-Schild?
Das Ork-Schild sieht hässlich aus, oder?
Wir bleiben mal bei unserem hier
Ja, das ist besser
What's that?
Tja, was ist das?
Ich mein, wir wissen, dass ein Monster hier rumfliegt
Das wird's ja wohl sein
Oh, oh
Ja, okay
Wie kill ich den jetzt?
Mit meinen krassen Bogenskills, hä?
Gute Idee, Lea
Gute Idee
Kommst du her?
Lass Lea in Ruhe, kommst du her?
Schreckt!
In your...
Oh
Da ist er down
Ich kann schon verstehen, dass sie den Held geil findet
Ich mein...
You know, if it had been me
I would have thanked you
Properly
There should be a way through
Should be
Ähm...
Wollte ich nicht sagen
Keine Ahnung
Ich...
Good luck
What? No goodbye kiss?
Ja, wie gesagt
Ich kann schon verstehen, dass die Schafe auf den Held sind
Ich mein, du musst dir überlegen
Innerhalb von 2 Stunden
Quasi vom 0815-Nichts-Gönner-Zauberlehrling
Zum Drachentöter
Zum Goblin-Töter
Zum Nekromanten-Owner
Zum Zyklopen-Basher
Also, mehr kannst du nur
an Mänlichkeit echt nicht erwarten
Spodas
größere Spodas
piss dich
Aua, ich bekomm damage
You have been poisoned, you need to drink
Anti. Habe ich so was?
Wow, noch mehr Spodas
Stoneskin
Full health, da nehmen wir mal meinen jetzt
habe ich...
Benem? Ah hier, Antidote
Sehr schön.
Öh!
Und, Alter.
Okay, die so zu attackieren hat keinen Sinn.
Das müssen wir anders machen.
Alter.
Was ist das für ein Kack-Gegner?
Die werden hier...
Jump-Slashed!
Wir wissen ja, dass das Gift aufhört,
sobald wir low-level sind.
Äh, low-leben sind.
Deswegen kämpfen wir einfach mal low-level.
Mit wenig Leben.
Komm her.
Die Sounds.
Hör doch die Sounds an.
Oben? Unten?
Oben ist nix.
Wann kommt das Dual?
Ähm.
Ich hab den Thorsten, glaube ich,
in über einem Jahr oder so nicht mehr gesehen.
Ein Key.
Ein Key für was?
War irgendwo eine Truhe, die ich nicht aufgekriegt hab?
Okay, wo genau geht's lang?
Oh, noch mehr Spodos.
Hier?
Hier komm ich her, oder?
Hier komm ich her.
Da.
Ho, geschafft.
Eine kommt noch.
Die wird noch gebasht.
Damn.
Sehr schön.
Mana-Pausch.
Das war mal nett.
Overrated, she baited.
Sind wir wieder oben?
Okay.
Äh.
Also ist für Leute, die was gegen Spinnen haben,
ist das hier gar echt nix.
Wir wissen ja, das Gift killt uns nicht,
deswegen müssen wir auch kein Antidote nehmen.
Wir klitschen das Game einfach mal.
Oder was heißt klitschen?
Ich mein, es ist halt so programmiert.
Oh.
Bro.
Die Musik ist so, so,
so fancy noch.
Hier ist ja irgendwo noch ne Spinne am Start.
Ich seh keine mehr.
Ah, doch, da.
Was geht mit der Spinne ab?
Habt ihr's grad gesehen?
Die ist übelst rumgeklitscht.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Der Robo.
Der bringt's echt.
Die Musik ist immer noch so,
als wär hier was.
Aber hier ist nix mehr.
Außer die in die Wand geklitschte Spinne.
Spinne.
Klitschsboder.
Äh. What?
Alter.
Okay, die Musik ist vorbei.
Anscheinend ist das Game auch der Meinung, die Spinne ist zu lang in die Wand geklitscht.
Spoder.
Piss dich, Alter.
Die lebt noch.
Das war's jetzt aber, oder?
Alter, will mich das Game verarschen?
Hast du ne VR-Brille?
Nee, ich war kurz davor, mir ne HTC-Brille zu kaufen.
Wisst ihr was?
Scheiß drauf. Wie geht das?
Können wir skillen?
Nice. Ork-Schwert, Ink.
Wo ist es?
Yeah.
Haha!
Oh, jetzt wird geschreckt mit dem Ork-Schwert.
Spoder sind richtig heftig, ja.
Leute, ich hab hier neben mir schon die ganze Zeit Abendessen stehen.
Ich will zwar was futtern, aber ich krieg's wieder nicht gebacken.
Zu streben, sondern zu essen.
Ich frag mich, wie das Dance-Game oder irgendwelche anderen...
Also für Demon Grills würde ich
Liana sofort vergessen.
Wie kriegen die das immer hin, die ganzen anderen
Let's Play so mit Essen
und Spielen?
Mach doch eben Pause.
Was ist denn das?
Ah, Food.
Ja, dann machen wir mal ganz kurz
Pause.
Also Pause.
Pause. Ich lass natürlich
Streben an. Ich mach ein bisschen Musik an.
Ja, wenn ihr was wissen wollt,
schießt los, haut ein paar Fragen raus.
Gar nicht beantworten.
Ich werd mich einfach immer kurz muten, während ich kaue.
Ich muss ja nicht unbedingt ins Ohr schmatzen.
Und dann machen wir gleich weiter.
Einfach fluten.
Und wechsel auf Social Eating.
Ich glaub, der Trend ist vorbei.
Wenn der nächste YouTube-Crime kommt,
vielleicht im Dezember.
Wie gesagt, ich bin den ganzen Dezember da.
Allerdings macht mir Livestream
so irgendwie mehr Bock zur Zeit.
Auch wenn es natürlich für deutlich
weniger ist. Ich mein, hier
haben wir so, wenn ich irgendwelche Sachen
jetzt stelze hier, dann hab ich, was weiß ich,
um die 100 Zuschauer.
Wenn ich, sagen wir mal, sowas wie Black Ops mache
oder Battlefield oder so, da sind schon Tinken mehr.
Das ist natürlich nichts zu vergleichen
mit irgendwie 30k
oder mehr auf YouTube in einem Video.
Aber ich finde
es persönlich angenehmer.
So mit Chat.
Mit Twitch-Chat.
Dummen Twitch-Memes und
einfach in Ruhe
streben.
Ja. Klar kenn ich das.
Ich hab das sogar, wenn du mal guckst,
ich hab das sogar
auf Twitch. Äh, auf Twitch.
Auf Steam.
Aber ich wollte es ja direkt am Release-Tag
spielen, vielleicht auch im Stream. Allerdings
Problem ist,
die Server waren instant kaputt.
Seitdem hab ich es noch mal ausprobiert.
Ähm, mal gucken, wie die
Steam-Bewertungen mittlerweile sind.
Da bin ich gespannt. Wahrscheinlich
absolut grottenschlecht, weil die Server nicht
verfügbar waren. Gucken wir mal.
Wie geht's dem Garten?
Der stellt's noch so vor sich hin.
Mixed.
Äh, und ich hab noch
eine Idee, was wir gucken.
Steam Stats World.
Da gucken wir mal, wie viele Leute spielen.
Braucht man die App-ID?
Hä?
Okay, was auch immer.
Gut, dass wir die App-ID haben.
Nicht schlecht.
Schlägt sich doch eigentlich ganz gut.
Das schlägt sich doch
eigentlich ganz gut. Nicht schlecht.
Neuer Peak.
10k zur Primetime heute.
Also sprich,
dass die Zahlen nicht mit Early Access hochgegangen
sind, dann direkt auf nahezu null getroppt
sind, spricht eigentlich dafür, dass das Game
vom Ansatz her gar nicht so schlecht ist.
Schlägt sich doch gar nicht schlecht.
Ich mein, klar.
10k
sind im Vergleich zu einem Battlefield nix.
Was spielen
eigentlich gerade mal
im PC, wie viel spielen?
Das
ist gar nicht mal so viel, ne
Leute, das ist gar nicht mal so viel mehr.
Man muss aber auch
dazu sagen,
das ist allgemein nicht so viel.
Es ist halt so
fehl, ne, dass immer noch die Hälfte der Leute
Battlefield 4 spielen.
Oh, BF3-Stats kaputt, wie's aussieht.
Es spielen halt
ziemlich genau die Hälfte von Battlefield 1,
Battlefield 4.
Hm. Also da ging
diese Zahlen, ist das nicht schlecht.
Ich denke, das Game hat auf jeden Fall Potenzial,
wo ich ein bisschen Gedanken, äh, wo ich ein bisschen
Bedenken hab, ist, dass
der Hersteller, wenn man sich das nämlich mal
anguckt, wie macht man
das hier eigentlich?
Wie listet man, wie listet man Games
nach Hersteller? Hier.
Die haben nix.
Von denen gibt's, also,
außer Painkiller, ja,
das kenn ich, aber das ist schon, das ist ja
15 Jahre alt oder so.
Ähm, wobei das auch nur die Addons sind.
Glaub ich. Ansonsten haben
die nichts vorzuweisen.
Ich kenn das alles nicht.
Das, das hab ich schon mal irgendwo gehört,
glaub ich. Aber ansonsten,
ja, und die
anderen Sachen von denen haben jetzt auch nicht
gerade die
geilsten Bewertungen.
Naja.
Also, ich bin
da skeptisch, ob das
was wird.
Weiter futtern, sonst wird das mit 10 Minuten nix.
Daddels du momentan
viel, wenn ja, was?
Ähm, hält sich in Grenzen.
Ab und zu
Black Ops 4.
Und wenn man sich mal hier die Last
Plate anguckt in Steam.
Kann man das überhaupt?
Kann man in Steam
die Spiele irgendwie sortieren nach dem, was
man zuletzt gespielt hat?
Geht das?
Moment, ah, hier, ha.
Last Plate, ha ha.
Ja.
Da hab ich viele Stunden drin.
Also, nicht so viel hier auf Steam, ne.
Weil man sagen muss,
hier hab ich
viele Stunden reingesteckt.
Nein, nicht starten.
Come on, bruh.
Steam.
Ich wollte auf die Steam-Seite, nicht das Game starten.
Hach.
Okay, wie komm ich jetzt auf die...
Ah ja, guck, da hab ich 73 Stunden.
Da hab ich auch viel, das kennt aber wahrscheinlich keiner.
Da hab ich auch 77 Stunden.
Das Spiel ist übelst nice.
Es sieht absolut grottig aus, ich weiß.
Aber das ist echt gut.
Ich mein,
es sieht scheiße aus, aus heutiger Sicht, ja.
Also denken sich jetzt viele.
Aber ich find, es hat seinen Charme und es macht Bock.
77 Stunden.
Sag mal, kann das sein, dass da nur
die Dinger drinstehen, die man installiert hat?
Nee.
Bird Story wollt ich auch mal spielen. Ja, To The Moon haben wir ja
Let's Play-Sort.
Wie überlebst du mit 7 und 8?
Schmeiße ich zu oben rechts, indem ich sie eigentlich
einfach komplett ignoriere.
Holst du dir eigentlich Red Dead Redemption 2?
Ich weiß nicht.
Aus dem Grund,
weil ich eigentlich kein großartiger Fan bin
von, ähm,
Sandbox und Open World spielen.
Was gibt's zu essen?
Brötchen mit Salami.
Heute Mittag gab's, äh,
Dönerteller.
Wobei, was ich ja in letzter Zeit übelst gerne esse,
ist, äh,
Pide, Pide
Sucuk, falls man das so ausspricht.
Also quasi die mit
türkischer Salami.
Besser als Salami-Pizza.
Seit deinen Videos mit Emco einschalten,
wie der CSGO angefasst. Ja gut, der Emco hat im Prinzip
nur zweimal mitgespielt damals.
Ähm, aber
wie man sieht, nein.
102 Stunden ist in CS ja im Prinzip
nix.
CSGO ist RIP. Warum? Ich hab gelesen,
dass in CSGO jetzt, ähm,
die, äh,
was war das, die AUG und die
SSG
angepasst haben, sodass man die sich quasi
anstatt der AK und der M4 kaufen kann.
Und dass jetzt viele so den großen
Meta-Umschwung in CS prophezeien.
Wo ich auch viele Stunden train, relativ viele Stunden,
für das da so ein olles Game ist, ist
Age of Empires 3.
Zweier hab ich auf Steam quasi nicht
gespielt.
Ah, Elrake war auch nice.
So, ein Brötchen noch,
dann ist Ruhe.
Für dich ist es RIP. Warum?
Also, du meinst jetzt für dich persönlich keinen Bock mehr?
Oder irgendwie
interessiert dich einfach nicht mehr?
Oder meinst du jetzt irgendwie,
du predictest, dass es demnächst
in den Bach runter geht?
Alles zusammen, okay.
Wie findest du das, dass viele Entwickler
ihre Spiele nicht mehr auf Steam entwickeln?
Naja, so viele sind's ja nicht.
Wer ist es denn?
Ich mein, das neue CoD ist jetzt
auf Battle.net.
Ubisoft macht mit ihrem
Uplay Crap
im Prinzip ähnliche Sachen,
wobei es die Dinger immer noch auf Steam gibt,
oder?
Ja.
Ähm.
Ansonsten, was ist es denn?
EA, ja okay.
Aber
FIFA juckt mich nicht.
Und das letzte
Battlefield fand ich scheiße.
Wie sehen eigentlich so die Steam Stats gerade aus?
Wahrscheinlich immer noch Pupke
vorne.
Also, my prediction.
Pupke,
Dota, CSGO.
Ja, nicht German.
Schon international.
Ja, okay.
So viele Leute
spielen Dota. Ist da gerade irgendwas?
Läuft da gerade irgendwas?
Ich kann mir eigentlich kaum
vorspielen, dass quasi gerade
mehr Leute Dota 2
spielen wie CS und
Pupke.
Oder spielen die
in China Pupke nicht über Steam, sondern
einen eigenen Launcher?
Dass Rust so viel immer noch spielt, finde ich
mega krass.
Also Rust und ARK, das sind Games, ne?
Wo du eigentlich nichts mehr von
hörst, aber anscheinend
immer noch ziemlich beliebt.
Was ist eigentlich aus ARK geworden? Ist das mittlerweile gut?
Wir haben einmal auf der Gamescom
bei dem Entwickler
und das
war mal eines der Sachen, wo du wirklich
die ganz normalen Entwickler
dort hattest. Also keine
speziell geprieften und keine Marketing
Leute. Ich hab das Mikrofon ein bisschen weg,
dass ich es futtern kann, ohne dass es euch ins Ohr
futtert.
Und das war
das einzige Mal auf der Gamescom, wo ich das
Gefühl hatte, hier bei ARK,
dass erstens die Entwickler ihr eigenes Game gerne
spielen
und zweitens, dass sie selbst ultra
gehypt sind auf den Krams, den sie
selbst verzappten gerade. Rocket League
finde ich nice, dass sich das so hält.
Habe ich nie wirklich
ernsthaft gespielt, aber das ist ein Spiel, wo ich es gut
finde, dass sich das hält.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind,
was macht eigentlich
was macht eigentlich gerade
der Dark
Nachfolger? Sind die jetzt eigentlich
mittlerweile
in ordentlicher Beta
drinne? Okay, anscheinend
schon. Letztes Mal, wo ich
reingeguckt habe, war das noch ziemlich
unfertig. Ist es aber wahrscheinlich immer noch. Ich glaube, das wird
auch wieder so ein Game, was nie fertig wird.
Was gibt es denn Schönes auf Kickstarter?
Ich würde übrigens gerne
einmal im Monat oder so
Ja, und das habe ich mir ganz
schamlos von Dance Gaming abgeguckt.
Ich würde gerne einmal im Monat
so eine Kickstarter
Projekt-Review
Geschichte machen.
Also sprich, wo wir uns die
neuesten Gaming und Gaming
bezogenen Kickstarter
Projekte machen gucken.
Warum sieht denn die Seite so
scheiße aus?
Weil da ist auch schon viel
Bullshit dabei.
Classic Singleplayer RPG,
was ist das denn?
Keine Ingame Sachen, ne?
Ich finde es cool, dass so Classic RPGs
jetzt wieder voll im Korn sind,
weil sie gemerkt haben, der Kram verkauft sich.
So.
Fertig.
Ich habe jetzt noch so ein Muffin stehen.
Ich glaube,
das Ding kann man eigentlich gar nicht Muffin nennen,
weil der eingefallen ist.
Das ist quasi ein flacher Muffin.
Da muss ich auch mal kurz
auch noch was von reinhauen.
Ja, das, ups,
das können wir aber echt mal machen.
Einmal im Monat so eine
Kickstarter
Kickstarter-Review-Geschichte, weil da ist
immer viel Interessantes dabei und natürlich auch
übelst viel absoluter
Crap, ja.
So diese ganzen
RPG-Maker-Games so,
wo dann der Typ oder seine
Freundin quasi das Voice-Over
noch selbst eingesprochen hat fürs Video kurz.
Naja,
ich backe in letzter Zeit fast nichts mehr.
Seit ich mit der
Hose gescampt wurde.
Was macht eigentlich die Hose? Muss ich mal gucken.
Gibt es da eigentlich was Neues
mittlerweile von?
Updates.
Moment, on missing rewards?
Wollt ihr mich ver...
Es geht mir nicht um missing rewards,
es geht um die Hose an sich,
die noch nicht angekommen ist.
Wie, ich muss mich anmelden?
Ja, scammed
haben sie mich.
Hallo, na, Interesse mal bei der Bahn
vorbeizukommen? Äh, prinzipiell schon.
Ich hab mir jetzt sogar
angeguckt, was das, oh wie hieß das?
Sky...
Nicht
SkyNet, SkyTower?
SkyDeck?
Irgendwie so? Wie hieß das?
Das ist das
Innovationszentrum von der Bahn. Ich hab mir
sogar mal angeguckt, was das ist.
Und das ist ja quasi bei uns am Hauptbahnhof.
In Frankfurt. Also prinzipiell
schon, ja.
SkyDeck, ja genau, SkyDeck.
Prinzipiell schon.
Wobei ich da ein schlechtes Gewissen hab, ne?
Weil sich ja teilweise die Leute so krass
unflamen auf Twitter, und wenn man die Leute auf Twitter
unflamt, ist das was anderes, als
wenn man sie in echt sieht.
So ist das halt.
Ich reg mich ja manchmal schon
übertrieben auf, ja.
Da wär ich wahrscheinlich gleich verhaftet,
wenn ich mich bei der Bahn blicken lasse.
Aber prinzipiell schon, ja.
Prinzipiell find ich die Idee nicht schlecht.
Ja, ich sag dir Bescheid.
Hm.
Wo wir grad beim Bahnen sind, was ich lustig finde in letzter Zeit,
morgens,
also so um,
keine Ahnung, 7 Uhr oder so,
also wo keiner so auf Twitter sonst was schreibt,
...
da trendet die Bahn
öfters auf Twitter.
Allerdings trendet die Bahn nicht,
weil, ähm,
irgendwas wäre oder so,
sondern, weil
die normalen Statusmeldungen von
allen möglichen Bahn-Twitter-Accounts,
weil irgendwas ist,
ausreichen,
mit der geringen Gesamtposting-Anzahl
auf Twitter zu dieser Uhrzeit,
dass Bahn trendet.
Einfach durch die ganz normalen Bahn-Messages,
die so geschickt werden.
Das musst du erst mal schaffen.
Quasi, Twitter trendt durch
...
kein Trend.
Ja, mach ich.
Ja, hier wurde ich gescamt.
So, mein Muffin ist gleich weg, gleich gehts game weiter.
Moin, Floxig.
Ja, hier haben sie mich gescamt.
Und seitdem,
es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich sagen würde,
oh mein Gott, ich geh jetzt pleite,
weil sie mich gescamt haben.
Ganz furchtbar schlimm.
Und auch nicht, weil ich es nicht wusste, irgendwie.
Ich mein, mir ist klar, dass
Backen von Projekten irgendwo Risiko
ist.
Ja, dass du nicht weißt, was du kriegst.
Aber irgendwie hab ich seitdem
kaum Bock, was zu backen.
Original sind zwei
hab ich gebackt, und eins glaub ich auch.
Gruß vom Krieger.
Ja, zurück.
Ist er grad bei dir in der Nähe?
Oder wie kommst du drauf?
So, fertig gefordert, game geht weiter.
Spoda.
Aber das gescamt
werden auf Kickstarter ist nicht schön.
Du hast halt auch keine Chance,
so dieses, ihr seht ja die ganzen Typen,
die da in den Comments schreiben,
ich mache von meinem Recht
Gebrauch zurücktreten,
vor allem von meinem Recht.
Auf Kickstarter.
Auf Kickstarter hast du erstmal kein Recht, in dem Sinne.
Bei Kickstarter ist es
wie bei jeder anderen Online-Plattform, als erstes
hat man die Online-Plattform recht.
Und wenn die sagt,
du hast kein Recht, dann hast du kein Recht.
So ist das.
Jetzt ist es auf Twitter und YouTube.
Wenn YouTube heute der Meinung ist,
äh, kann man da
irgendwie hoch?
Wenn YouTube
heute der Meinung ist,
Max, dein Account wird terminated,
dann ist es
vollkommen egal, ob ich was gemacht habe
oder nicht.
Ich bin, wie sagt man so schön heutzutage,
gefickt.
Was ist denn das schon wieder für eine komische Steuerung?
Achso.
Alter, leck mich.
Brauche ich eher das Zeug.
Max-God-Movement.
Das ist scheiße.
Du kannst doch nicht viel anders moven.
Alter.
Ah.
Das Game hat keinen Bock.
Wird zu doof.
Gibt es eh nichts.
Paar Healtränke, wozu braucht man das denn?
Hatte gemovement.
Leute, es geht nicht anders.
Das ist halt so steif, das Game,
was movement angeht.
Oh, da musst du
jetzt runterjumpen.
Ah.
Ein Lever.
Ein Lever, ja.
Genau, Max.
Habt ihr gesehen, den Lever?
Okay.
Wo ist mein Bow?
Oh.
Der kriegt jetzt einen Header.
Wo muss das so machen?
Richtig krasser.
Header.
Heador.
Best.
Poggers.
Der hat es nicht mal lange gemacht.
Bam.
Oh.
Oh fuck, ich treff nix.
Ich treff nix.
Von wann ist das Game?
2008.
Oh, die werden aber geschreckt,
die Goblins.
Was ist hier? Was war das?
Schild. Brauch man nicht.
Oh, da ist ja noch mehr.
Achtung. Achtung, Leute.
Oh, ne.
Ich wollte kicken.
Die Dinger sind scheiße
zu treffen.
Die Dinger sind echt
scheiße zu treffen.
Zack.
Schreckt.
Ist da noch was?
Wie viel sind denn da noch?
Oh.
Game?
Come on, bra.
Was ist denn das jetzt?
Fuck, Alter.
2 Gigabyte
in 2018.
Das ist halt einfach...
Wobei man das gar nicht so sagen kann,
weil das Game ist ja von 2008.
Aber das Game hat halt Probleme,
solange es mehr RAM braucht.
Aber anscheinend hat es gespeichert.
Das ist schon mal gut.
Ja, hau ab. Auch gut, kann ich mitleben.
Zu krass geownt.
Geh ich auch von aus.
Schreckt.
Hmm.
Oh.
Oh. Fallen.
Get roasted.
Hört sich fast an wie der...
Steffs. Steffs sacken.
Hört sich fast an wie der Assassin's Creed Sound.
Kann man den Steff bashen?
Outplayed.
Die Falle.
Der hat outplayed.
Ach, hier kann man
Mana laden.
So, und der Rest ist zu. Ja.
Okay.
Wo geht's weiter?
Diesen Windeffekt kenn ich doch. Welchen?
Du meinst im Hintergrund die...
Äh, warum?
Genau, kann man hier hoch?
Au.
Arsch angefackelt.
Was haben wir hier?
Der Coding Chris.
Das kann der Coding Chris.
Oh, nice Dolchors.
Jawoll.
Jetzt wird gemessert.
Marathon Lightweight
Kommando. Jetzt wird gemessert.
Guck. Habt ihr das gesehen?
So geht das.
So bist du in MW2 auch
gesprungen. Mit dem Messer.
Hier sind Orks.
Stellskill.
Es ist ein langer Weg.
Stellskill. Achtung.
Stellskill.
Rekt.
Nächster Stellskill.
Ne, kein Stellskill.
Stellskick.
Ui. Da fliegt er.
Oh, da kommen noch mehr.
Getschreckt.
Achtung.
Oh, nice.
Da fliegt er.
Haben wir noch was zu werfen?
Zack.
Alle down.
Ne, nicht down. Fast down.
Äh.
Nice Wurf.
Geh runter.
Aufstehen, Ork.
Und jetzt runter fliegen.
Woah.
Moment, Sarath.
Let's look around.
Oh.
We'll have to fix it.
Taking the stairs will do you some good anyway.
With luck we'll find a way to repair it on our way out.
Rambockt.
Das hat uns aber nicht so viel hergegeben hier.
Ah, man kann es aufmachen.
Was haben wir hier?
Lightning Dagger und Mana.
Was kann der Lightning Dagger?
Plus 4.
Das macht der hier auch.
Also macht der hier plus 4 und 4 Prozent Critical Hit.
Die normalen Daggers kann man wegschmeißen.
Und der macht plus 4...
Plus 8 gegen...
Licht...
Elektrizität...
Anfällige Gegner.
Woher soll ich denn wissen, welche Gegner Elektrizität anf...
Hallo?
Game?
Ich dachte schon, ich bin stuck.
Das wär's jetzt gewesen, ne?
Secretraum rein, erstmal stuck.
Das geht.
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung, Achtung.
Jawoll.
Direkt.
Achtung, der wird auch gekickt.
Diese fliegen.
Oh, Bogey, Bogey.
Da kann ich nichts gegen machen.
Da kann ich nichts...
War das der von da oben?
Der wär aber ganz schön schnell gewesen, wenn das der von da oben gewesen wär.
Nee. Komm her.
Komm her, komm her, komm her, komm her, komm her.
Alter.
Lol.
Okay, die Gegner sind nicht die hellsten, ne?
Noch einer.
Okay, komm her.
Bam, Fuß.
Hier sind Autokarten.
Warum jump ich hier drüber?
Egal.
Das sind Orks.
Das heißt, das ist voll Immersion.
Volles immersives Spielerlebnis.
Dass die Orks so blöd sind.
Oh.
Das war keine so gute Idee.
Was machen wir denn jetzt?
Revolution, ja.
Ah, da. Guck mal.
Aha.
Ah.
So, so, so.
Oh, Leute. Ich hab ne Idee.
Pog. Poggers. Poggers. Achtung.
Massive Poggers.
Wenn man treffen könnte.
Meint ihr, das geht?
Müsste funktionieren, oder?
Ich mein, der offizielle Weg vom Game gewollt ist ja nur eindeutig der hier.
Oh, was ist das?
Pogpilz.
Der offiziell gewollte Weg ist der hier.
Ah.
Aber wir probieren den anderen auch mal.
Ob das funktioniert.
Müsste eigentlich, oder?
Ich mein, es ist wahrscheinlich nicht gedacht vom Hersteller so.
Easy.
Wasser.
Oh.
Was ist das?
Souldrinker.
Plus 4?
Ich hab...
Mein Billigschwert hat plus 7.
Ah, Lifeleech-Waffe!
Require Strength 3.
Oh ne, das krieg ich ja ewig net.
Nehmen wir mal auf.
Ich muss mal Inflare machen.
Ich lese mal alle Books, falls wir irgendwas Relevantes für die Story haben.
Ich hoffe, das sind keine Quest-Items, die ich droppe.
Wenn nicht, sie liegen hier im Wasser.
Speedrun Strats.
So sieht's aus.
Ich scheine ein natürliches Talent zu haben für Speedrun Strats.
Und die offensichtlichsten Sachen check ich dafür nicht.
Stellskill.
Super.
Schinken.
Bleibt ihr hier?
Haha.
Rekt.
Uh, der hat aber dick gefressen, ey.
Was haben wir hier? Eine Rope.
Die wir nicht brauchen.
Von hier unten sind wir gestartet.
Ah, wir hätten auch hier hochklettern können.
Ich hätte gar nicht rumlaufen müssen.
Verstehe.
Hier waren wir schon.
Oh, noch mehr Spodas.
Rekt.
Manosaurus schreckt.
So, was haben wir denn hier?
Oh, die Spinne.
Knochen gegen Kopf.
Ja, der kann halt nicht gerade werfen.
Oh.
Spinne down.
Haben wir hier noch was?
Nö.
Du weißt nicht, wie lange das Spiel interessant bleibt.
Das geht bis zum Schluss.
Also, die haben hier wirklich bei dem Game,
du hast hier wirklich, ähm,
äh, klasse Statsmasse.
Das Game ist nicht lang, das geht, keine Ahnung,
sechs Stunden oder so.
Und dafür ist komplett abwechslungsreich durch die ganze,
durch die ganze Kampagne durch.
Äh.
Ah!
MonkaS.
Mein Memeboard ist kaputt.
Jetzt geht's wieder.
Das Memeboard macht das Game kaputt, was soll das?
Das muss ich nochmal optimieren.
Wie komme ich da vorne hin?
Hä?
Wie komme ich da hin?
Welches Board hast du? Mein selbstgebasteltes.
Ich kenne so ein Programm auch gar nicht.
Was das macht.
Ähm.
Okay, wie genau soll ich da vorne
dran kommen?
Vielleicht muss man einfach nur schnell sein.
Elgato Stream Deck. Ja, das
könnte ich mir auch holen.
Was ich halt doof finde an den
fertigen Lösungen ist, ich zeige es dir mal,
dass man die Bilder halt selbst nicht sieht.
Ich sehe die Bilder
ja bei mir als Overlay selbst.
Das heißt, ich kann sie auch nicht vergessen auszumachen.
Wie genau komme ich da vorne dran?
Irgendwie
einer, weil das sieht nach einer nicen Rüstung aus.
Könnte das funktionieren?
Meint ihr das geht?
Okay, ich habe ehrlich
gesagt.
Ah. Ah.
Oh. Nice.
Huh.
So, was gab es denn da jetzt eigentlich schönes?
Plate Armor.
Sehr nice.
Aber wir können doch nicht mal Chain Armor anziehen.
Dazu brauchen wir noch 3 Skill Points.
Meint ihr das war so gedacht vom Hersteller
das Rätsel so zu lösen?
Max für die komplette Meme-Experience.
Ja, deswegen habe ich auch selbst was programmiert.
Meint ihr das war so gedacht?
Oder mal umgedreht, wie hätte man das Rätsel
normal gelöst?
Sollte es nicht so gedacht gewesen
sein?
Definitiv nicht.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass es so gedacht war.
Aber die Frage ist,
wie es sonst gedacht war.
Übrigens, das ist auch eine Sache,
die finde ich cool in alten Games.
Man kann oftmals Sachen anders
lösen, als sie gedacht sind.
Ohne, dass das Spiel
irgendwie breakt.
Super langsam zu laufen.
Oder gekrautscht
laufen vielleicht, oder so.
Kann man sich hinlegen in dem Spiel eigentlich?
Nee.
Prone gibt es nicht.
Ja, das finde ich auch gut.
Weißt du, bei vielen neueren Games hast du dann gleich so instant
Sie verlassen das Schlachtfeld, kehren sie um.
Böh, tot.
But who?
A book.
So, this is where
Banalags Expedition made its last stand.
I'll bet they're the ones
who block the elevators
to keep the orcs out.
Ich habe da keine Bücher auf, ja.
War ich ja eh schon nicht.
Nee, hier komme ich her.
Hier geht's...
Ah, hier geht's weiter.
Hoffentlich nicht.
Noch mehr Spodas.
It's still in one piece.
Do you think the orcs have worked it?
Orcs aren't stupid.
Give it a try.
Skateboards.
Können wir Endos backen?
Nope.
Ich habe nichts zum
craften, ich habe bloß eine Steelbar,
die habe ich schon gekraftet.
There's nowhere to go but down from here.
Ich habe ja...
Im Schifflevel habe ich ja das
Crafting-Material nicht gefunden.
Ich habe vergessen wo es war.
Ich weiß nur noch im Hinterkopf, dass es da eins gegeben hat.
Aber keine Ahnung mehr,
wo das genau war.
Deswegen können wir uns jetzt nicht unser OP-Schwert craften.
Allerdings brauchen wir das auch nicht.
Das Orc-Schwert ist gut genug.
Das kann man theoretisch bis zum Schluss sogar verwenden.
Also durchschaffen wir es heute
nicht mehr.
Das nicht, aber wir schaffen...
Die Hälfte schaffen wir gut.
Dann spielen wir morgen den Rest.
Guck mal, sogar meine Robes sind noch da.
Ja, ich weiß nicht wie gut sich das Game verkauft hat,
aber ich kann mir schon vorstellen, nicht gut. Aber ich verstehe es nicht.
Das ist echt nice.
Das ist eines meiner Lieblingsgames.
Generell auf dieser Liste,
die ich da vorgelesen habe, was wir alles noch spielen werden,
sind ja nur Games, die mir gefallen.
Ich will ja kein Crap spielen.
Was haben wir hier zu bieten?
Goblins.
Bleibst du hier?
Der macht nix mehr.
Oh, was da? Was da? Was da?
Da ist was im Fahrstuhl gewesen.
Einmal die Woche Crap spielen?
Nee, an Crap habe ich keinen Spaß.
Das ist das Problem.
Endlich...
Oh nice, da kann ich theoretisch unendlich viel
Pfeile verschießen.
Allerdings habe ich kein Bogenskill.
Doch.
Weltherrschaft.
Wer hat das hier gebaut?
Die Servanten des siebten Drogons.
Sie waren klug mit ihren Händen
und hatten 1.000 Jahre, um es zu machen.
Also warum sind Orks hier?
Ich glaube, sie haben es übernommen.
Sie kamen nach den Kriegen des Blutes
und ihre Schamanen haben wahrscheinlich
die Macht des Verteidigungs-
Alter, habe ich mich erschreckt.
Ihr wisst ja, ich habe es mit Spinnen allgemein nicht so.
Und wenn man
das ekligste und gruseligste
ist immer, wenn man Sachen nicht
direkt sieht.
Ich bin relativ resistent,
was so
Jumpscares anbelangt und sowas.
Aber sowas, ey.
Das ist eklig, wo du was siehst und nicht genau
sicher bist, ob du es gesehen hast.
Und dann guckst du hin und siehst es wirklich.
Das ist immer...
Mon KS ist das.
4 HP calculated.
Ich glaube, das wird so nichts.
Nein!
Nein! Ich stecke mit dem Kopf!
Mit dem Kopf in der Decke!
Please, game!
Okay, ich glaube, ich muss reloaden.
Ja, zum Glück gab es bei solchen Games auch sowas wie
Quicksave und Quickload.
Ohne das wäre er komplett RIP.
Stell dir mal vor, du hast ein Checkpoint-System,
was dann auch noch unfair ist.
Und dann passiert dir so ein Scheiß.
Da regst du dich ja doppelt auf.
Ich finde es geil, wie ihr das Schwert immer so rausholt.
So.
So, als müsste man das Schwert
einmal so geil drehen.
Vor allem, weil man so ein, keine Ahnung,
4 Kilo schweres Ork-Schwert auch so geil drehen kann.
Äh.
Oh.
Oh, knapp.
Doch, es ist nicht abgebrochen.
Ein Secret.
Secret mit jeder Menge Crap, den wir nicht brauchen.
Was haben wir hier?
Ring of Fire Protection.
Staff. Staff ist Kacke.
Das war's. Hat sich mal überhaupt nicht gelohnt,
dass wir hier so her sind.
Hat sich mal gar nicht gelohnt. Crap.
5 HP.
Calculated.
Oh.
Oh, ob wir das schaffen?
Jop. Nice.
Ach, Leute,
wir haben noch einen Ring, der Leben rackt, ne?
Deswegen kriegen wir Leben wieder.
Eigentlich müssen wir nur lange genug rumstehen,
dann haben wir noch volle Leben.
Was hältst du eigentlich von Kingdom Come Deliverance?
Das wollte ich unbedingt spielen.
Unbedingt.
Hab ich noch nicht. Unbedingt.
Hab ich noch nicht.
Aber ich glaub, das ist nix für nen Stream,
weil das wahrscheinlich ein Game ist,
was irgendwie wieder 15 Stunden oder so geht.
Unbedingt wollte ich das spielen,
weil das wohl das einzige Game sein soll,
wo Mittelalter mal ein bisschen realistisch ist.
It's magnificent.
Except that it's dead.
Bring it back to life and we can be on our way.
Nice.
Da passiert irgendwas.
Ich hau mir mal Rationen rein.
Ich find's eh blöd, wie...
mittelalterlich, ähm...
Also wie wenig mittelalterlich Mittelalterspiele sind.
Fängt ja schon an, dass die Leute in Mittelalterspielen immer dreckig sind.
Warum hätten die sich nicht im Mittelalter mal waschen sollen?
Wasser war ja nicht das Problem.
Ja, oder wenn sie dann irgendwelche Schlachten schlagen
und einfach in zwei Reihen sinnlos aufeinander zurennen,
was halt nachweislich, ja,
und es zigtausende Quellen und Sachen für gibt,
nicht so gewesen ist.
Aber im Mittelalter und Fantasy Sachen machen das gerne.
aber im Mittelalter und Fantasy Sachen machen das gerne.
So. Setzten wir mal den Crystal ein.
...
Ich wollte eigentlich, ähm, äh, Rüstungsbecken.
Wie lang, wie lang, wie lang geht das Game?
Also, Kingdom Come Deliverance?
Ach, Oberorg, du wirst jetzt gereckt.
Gereckt wirst du.
360 No Scope.
Ich glaube, der hat Loot am Gürtel.
Ich glaube auch, dass der Loot am Gürtel hat.
Wie kommst du da drauf?
Also, ich fand es jetzt nicht so ersichtlich, dass der Loot am Gürtel hat.
Ähm, schreckt.
Next, please.
Bam, in your face.
Oh, oh, oh, fuck, das hätte ich nicht machen sollen.
Was steht ihr Kack-Orks da auch im Weg?
Nein, oh, fuck, ich hatte gerade eine Down.
Scheiße.
Ha, Oberorg ist der Arsch.
Oberorg wurde gereckt.
Ich glaube, so war das nicht geplant vom Game.
So, Orks, guck mal hier.
Oh, nee.
Ich wollte euch doch nur an euren Häuptling...
Strange, Stranger.
Boah, Ork, du bist richtig clever.
Big Brain.
Null.
Oh, fuck.
Scheiße.
Ah, Kacke.
Ich-ich own die jetzt noch, die Orks.
Bam.
Schild signt mal.
Die Orks werden definitiv noch geowned von mir jetzt.
Orks rekt.
2 HP.
Easy, kack.
Kein Problem.
Jetzt können wir die Tür aufmachen.
Was passiert, wenn man mit einem Seilbogen auf die schießt?
Man macht einen Damage.
Was nicht viel ist, wenn die dich auch mit einem Bogen in der Hand...
Oh, wir können...
Wir können Zeugs anziehen.
Endu.
Chainmail.
Sehr gut.
Danach können wir uns jetzt sparen.
Jetzt haben wir die wichtigsten Sachen.
Weißt du, Sarath, wenn alles gut geht, wirst du bald deinen Vater sehen.
Hier? Was meinst du?
Es ist schwer zu erklären, aber ich bin sicher, dass er hier sein schönes, junges Sohn sehen wird, das Skal der Schatten.
Das klingt... seltsam. Ist er ein Art Geist?
Ich glaube, du könntest das sagen.
Aber ich bin mir nicht sicher, dass er so gesprochen werden würde.
Mein Vater... Ich habe ihn noch nie kennengelernt.
Warum ist er so wichtig?
Er ist eine sehr mächtige, sehr potente Person.
Wie jede mächtige Person hat er mächtige Feinde.
Was bedeutet das? Wer?
Na, den siebten Dragon zum einen.
Max arbeitet nur Vollzeit als Developer.
Weder noch.
Also ich arbeite nicht Vollzeit und ich arbeite auch nicht als Developer.
Ich arbeite nicht als reiner Developer.
Ich programmiere zwar schon Sachen, aber ich kümmere mich eigentlich hauptsächlich um unsere Source-Code-Verwaltung und schaue, dass wir einmal im Monat einen Release rauskriegen von unserer Software.
Inklusive Hotfixes für die alten Versionen, die Leute nerven, wenn es manche Konflikte gibt.
Nerven ist gut, ja.
Schreckt.
Ja, mach.
Weg ist er.
Sowas wie Scrum Master? Nein, nein, nein.
Zum Glück nicht.
Ich kümmere mich hauptsächlich um unser...
Oh, fuck!
Um unser Software-Repo, also sprich...
Ich sag da gleich was zu.
Also, äh...
Den muss ich jetzt bashen, den Typen.
Erstmal healen.
Na, also ich guck, dass sich keine Changes in die Quere kommen.
Und wenn ja, schnapp ich mir die Leute und guck, dass das gemerged wird.
Ähm...
War wenig schon?
Ich mach...
Hotfix...
Was war das?
Rope brauchen wir nicht.
Hotfixes für unsere alten Versionen.
Guck, dass regelmäßig im Monat...
...ein Release kommt.
Komplett.
Überall hinkommt, inklusive Tests.
Falls es da wieder Fehler gibt...
...will ich dann mit den Leuten schwätzen,
die das gemacht haben.
Ja, und inzwischen programmier ich natürlich auch noch Sachen.
Allerdings eher zur Verwaltung.
Zum Beispiel haben wir so eine Host-Übersicht,
die hab ich gebastelt.
In Groovy.
Wurde noch niemals in Groovy gemacht, aber es musste unbedingt in irgendwas
Java-basiertem sein.
Also JVM-basiertem.
Weil die Plattform drunter JVM-basiert ist.
Nicht, dass ich da Bock drauf gehabt hätte, aber...
...ist nicht dran vorbeigekommen.
Ähm...
Schauen wir mal.
Das hatten wir doch schon.
Wie kriegen wir diesen komischen Zyklop kaputt?
Aber es kann durchaus sein, dass...
...das in anderen...
...Firmen...
...einen Scrum Master macht.
The fuck?
Was soll denn das hier?
Das kann schon sein.
Aber ich bin kein Certified Scrum Master.
Ich glaub...
...dass wir bei uns in der Firma auch noch nicht...
...im Jahr...
...2018 angekommen...
...dass wir solche Positionen ordentlich...
...besetzt hätten, die dann auch nicht...
...das nur machen, weil es auf dem Papier...
...steht, sondern so wie es gedacht ist.
Da brauchen wir noch ein bisschen für.
Wir sind was sowas anbelangt...
...nicht wirklich...
...auf der Höhe der Zeit.
Aber ich muss sagen...
...das ist einer der Gründe, warum ich es da an sich...
...gar nicht so schlecht finde.
Da kommt nicht laufend...
Wow.
Wir rennen nicht...
...wenigstens wie jeder...
...oder wie vielen anderen jedem Hype hinterher.
Wir machen zwar auch viel Blödsinn...
...aber, sag mal so, Richtung...
...Bank-Versicherung...
...die sind da halt alles ein bisschen...
...konservativer.
Es gibt bei uns auch sau viel Kobold-Zeugs...
...und sowas noch.
Ich hatte eine bei mir in der Ausbildung...
...mit dabei.
Ein nice Developer-Grill.
Die hat extra...
...wie mach ich den platt?
Die hat extra Kobold gelernt...
...dass sie danach wer verdient.
Was ja schon...
...eine nice Idee ist.
Wobei, ich sag mal so, mich hätt's genervt.
Komm mal her.
Äh...
Ah, das hat funktioniert.
Das hat bloß rumgebackt.
Schreckt.
Was für eine Art von Software ist das?
Das größte, was wir haben...
...ist, ähm...
Tja, wie erzähl ich das jetzt am besten?
Ohne dass es zu offensichtlich ist...
...was es für ein Laden ist.
Also das größte, was wir haben, ist quasi...
...für den Außendienst...
...eine Software-Plattform.
Eine Plattform, wo die quasi...
...ihr Zeug mit verwalten können.
Sagen wir mal so.
Wobei, darum kümmere ich mich nicht.
Software-technisch.
Dann haben wir noch jede Menge...
...Server-Configs.
Ähm...
Ich hab ne Donation gekriegt.
50€ vom Sebaro!
Wieder krasser Scheiß.
Hab schon lang kein Schutzgeld mehr bezahlt.
Lull.
Bin richtig auf die nächsten Streams gehypt und die Games.
Nice. Schön, dass ihr das gefällt, Sebaro.
Ähm...
Also egal, was ihr für ne Firma sagt.
Ich werd jetzt nicht sagen, ja oder nee.
Ja, was wir halt vieles haben...
...sind noch...
...wild gewachsene...
...kreuz...
...und quer...
...Ähm...
...Krams für die ganzen Server-Typen...
...die es bei uns gibt.
Da guck ich eigentlich zum größten Teil drauf...
...dass die Dinger noch...
...ordentlich geupdatet werden...
...und ähm...
...versorgt werden mit neuesten Sachen.
Let's get the skull and be far away from here...
...before Arantir sticks what's left of his nose in here.
You go first. Make sure that it's safe.
Die kommst du aber. Richtig!
Ja.
Was gar nicht so einfach ist...
...weil...
...wenn sie über 20 Jahre da Dinger angesammelt haben...
...und wenn man quasi anstatt...
...ein Datenbank-Typ...
...acht verschiedene hat...
...dann ist das teilweise schon ein bisschen...
...subordinär.
Das ist auch optimal.
Hat was von Gollum, oder?
Ja, ist die Frage damit beantwortet? Ähm...
...also...
...ich tu mir schwer im Detail, was...
...oh, Story Mode.
Nein, nur zwischen uns?
Sie war nicht dein Typ.
Vergiss sie! Lauf!
Ja, lauf, du Abomination!
Ich werde sie finden.
Okay, wir halten das mal fest.
Das Zauberer-Grill kann ohne Probleme die Tür hochheben.
Der super-ober-krass-mächtige...
...Nekromancer kann das nicht.
Das bedeutet...
...dass, ähm...
...quasi der Skill des...
...Türhochhebens eine exklusive Sache für...
...die Zauberer-Grill-Klasse ist.
Alessa kann ich mir das nicht erklären.
Ich war noch nicht mal Demon-Grill-Kanz.
Das Grill ist doch nicht wirklich Shrek'd.
Kann dazu jetzt nichts sagen.
Story Spoiler oder sowas.
Der hat falsch geskillt. Der ist versichert.
Respekt, ja.
Da muss man unbedingt respekten, der Typ.
Irgendjemand wollte wissen, was ich von Assassin's Creed Odyssey denke.
Ich habe es mir nicht gekauft.
Obwohl ich, wenn ich die Auswahl hätte zwischen Griechenland und Ägypten, hätte ich eindeutig Griechenland genommen.
Und der Grund, warum ich es mir nicht gekauft habe, ist nicht, weil es ein schlechtes Game an sich ist.
Beziehungsweise ist es halt so ein Assassin's Creed, wie halt die letzten paar Assassin's Creed so sind.
Sondern, weil ich keinen Bock habe auf Open World.
Das ist echt mein Problem bei vielen Games.
Ich hätte schon Bock auf die Main Quest.
Vor allem, wenn sie gut gemacht ist.
Aber nicht auf 80 Stunden Türme erobern und bringen Fetch Quests und solchen Dingern.
Echt.
Was hast du genau für eine Ausbildung gemacht?
Ich habe, also gelernt habe ich, schon über 10 Jahre her.
Fachinformatiker, Systemintegration und danach habe ich irgendwie 2 oder 3 Jahre bei dem Laden gearbeitet, wo ich die Ausbildung gemacht habe.
Bin ich woanders hin?
Da bin ich jetzt immer noch.
RIP.
Da ist leider nichts mehr.
Wobei ich mir überlegt habe, ob ich mir nicht nächstes Jahr mal was anderes suchen soll.
Es gibt ein paar Sachen, die gehen mir ein bisschen auf den Keks.
Da, wo ich jetzt bin.
Und mal was anderes machen, ist auch nicht so verkehrt.
Au!
Hast du nach wie vor eine 4-Tage-Woche?
Ja, das werde ich auch nie wieder anders machen.
Also das ist auch Voraussetzung dafür, wenn ich woanders hingehe, dass sie das mitmachen.
Aber bei uns in Frankfurt ist es halt so, in der Umgebung, es suchen wirklich viele händeringend Leute.
Vor allem Leute, die auch ein bisschen Ahnung von dem haben, was sie machen.
Labersäcke gibt es genug.
Die eigentlich keinen Plan haben von dem, was sie treiben.
Gefühlt oftmals, da komme ich wieder als Nuff.
Gefühlt oftmals auch irgendwelche krassen Consultants, die sich gut verkaufen können.
Aber bei näherem Hinschauen absolut keinen Plan haben von dem, was sie treiben.
Ah, hier geht es hoch.
Siehst du die Platte? Die vier Socket sind für die vier Gems.
Ergas weiß, wo die Firmen und diese zwei Gems sind.
der sache stehen wo man arbeitet ja also solange die leute cool sind mit dem man
arbeitet so lange so lange dass die atmosphäre und die technische sache
stimmt muss man nicht letztendlich nicht unbedingt großartig dahinter stehen also
sprich ich könnte auch bei der bahn arbeiten obwohl ich die bahn an sich
scheiße finde das wären dann für mich zwei getrennte sachen
ich meine es ist natürlich cool wenn man irgendwo ist und es auch noch mega geil
findet quasi die die firma an sich aber auf der anderen sache muss man ja auch
mal sagen es hat auch keinen sinn letztendlich sich zu sehr mit mit der
jeweiligen firma zu identifizieren weil letztendlich das machen die mit euch ja
auch nicht das habe ich jetzt gerade aufgehoben hat jemand gesehen was gerade
gelootet habe also ich finde man sollte sich da in irgendwie so einen
arbeitgeber nie zu sehr rein steigern so nach
die
motto ja also diese kleine große familie und vier nun da und sonst war es
manchmal haben sie ja alle jetzt endlich selbst wenn man das irgendwann mal
glauben sollte umgedreht es halt nicht so
deswegen hat eigentlich keinen sinn deswegen ist besser man hat das im
gewisse gewisse abstand dazu und denkt sich ja okay hier ist ja eigentlich ganz
nett aber quasi persönlich so richtig
Engaged bin ich
Ist man nicht, das ist eigentlich das beste
Was man machen kann
Was habe ich denn da jetzt gelootet eigentlich gerade
Keine Ahnung
Ist bei euch auch so, naja
Also wenn es bei uns wirklich
Nervig wird, dann tue ich mir irgendwas anderes
Ich könnte jetzt schon im Endeffekt mit dem ganzen
Zeug, was die letzten Jahre immer gemacht haben
Gemacht habe, wahrscheinlich
Drei Seiten Lebenslauf und fünf Seiten
Xing voll machen oder so, wenn es unbedingt sein muss
Aber
Ich würde dann im Endeffekt
Auch, also wenn ich mir wirklich was Neues suche
Wie gesagt, ich überlege mir das ja gerade für nächstes Jahr
Das würde ich dann wahrscheinlich auch
So mal die
Reichweite nutzen im Endeffekt, die ich jetzt habe
Weil ich
Habe schon öfters mal Leute gehabt
Die halt gefragt haben
Ob ich nicht was suche, also jetzt auch von den Streams
Hier oder auch von manchen YouTube Videos
Ich habe immer gesagt, nee, nee, ich bin da
Ich bin da gut unter
Und habe eigentlich keinen Bock
Kein Red Dead Redemption die Woche
Wahrscheinlich nicht
Oder vielleicht doch, ich weiß es noch nicht
Ich bin wahrscheinlich auch der Einzige auf der Welt
Der noch keinen GTA 5 Singleplayer durchgespielt hat
Ja, Pavilion Man
Deswegen ist es aber auch wichtig, dass man was kann
Weil, so mal als Beispiel
Es gibt ja ganz viele Firmen, die der Meinung sind
Oh, wir müssen jetzt sparen
Und dann kommt irgend so ein
So BWL Brain kommt dann auf die Idee
Und sagt, ja okay
Wir machen irgendwie so ein geiles Abfindungsprogramm
Oder irgendwie sowas
Das hört man ja auch öfters mal
Dass das größere Läden so machen
Das Problem
Bei solchen Abfindungsprogrammen ist
Dass da einmal
Die Leute abhauen, die du noch bräuchtest
Um quasi die nächste Generation ordentlich
Hervorzubereiten, nämlich die, die kurz vor der Rente sind
Die sagen sich, ey krass, mach mal
Zwei, drei Monatsgelder, snack ich mir
Snack ich mit, dann gehe ich in Rente
Ähm
Oder du hast welche, die halt
Easy was Neues finden
Oder welche, die ganz jung sind und auch woanders
Gute Aussichten haben, also sprich
Wenn du
Wenn du solche komischen Programme machst
Dann hast du am Ende eigentlich nur noch
Die, mit denen du eh nichts mehr anfangen kannst
Wisst ihr, wie ich meine?
Weil alle
Andere nehmen sonst die Abfindung und sagen, ja okay
Geh keinen Bock mehr drauf, ich hau ab
Deswegen ist sowas immer eigentlich eine ziemlich blöde Idee
Wo geht's hier eigentlich weiter?
Ach hier
Er hat kein Damage gemacht, nice
Oh
Alter, ich brauch Anlauf
Das sieht irgendwie so aus, als explodiert hier was
Oder auch nicht
Chainmail, haben wir schon
Jetzt explodiert's
Alter, was ist das denn?
Ich weiß auch gar nicht, so sehr ehrlich gesagt
In welchem Bereich ich jetzt
Als nächstes was machen würde
Au
Wollen wir mal neu laden, das kann's ja nicht sein
Ich mein, ich könnte wirklich in vielen Bereichen eigentlich was machen
Ich kann nicht
Servertechnisch mit Lilums kenne ich mich super aus
Ja, ohne Selbstlob, aber
Das muss man mal sagen
Wenn ich mir da teilweise angucke, was andere fabrizieren
Serverautomatisierung, generell hohe Verfügbarkeit, Clustergeschichten und sowas
Also, das ist eigentlich kein Ding
Programmieren, gar nicht
So die wichtigsten Sachen, die man braucht
Am liebsten natürlich in .Net
Allerdings kann ich auch meinetwegen was in JavaScript machen, wenn's unbedingt sein muss
Aber da würd ich mich nicht drum reißen
Wo geht's lang?
Kannste zu bunt gehen, naja
Git-Versionsverwaltung
Kenn ich mich eigentlich auch ziemlich gut aus
Jetzt halt nicht nur die 0815-Dinger
Sondern das, was man so lernt, weil man mehrere Jahre lang quasi
So ein Software-Release-Prozess
Nennen wir's mal, managt
Da macht man schon ein bisschen mehr Git-Magic, als man normalerweise sonst noch kennt
Sowas würde ich, das macht mir eigentlich Spaß
Wo genau geht's hier eigentlich lang?
Ja, also zumindest fange ich an
Falls ich was Neues noch muss ich mir natürlich da erstmal überlegen
Wie man das alles schön verpackt
Ja und alles, was ich jetzt gesagt hab
Das sind halt auch Sachen, wo ich nicht einfach nur was mitgemacht hab
Sondern wo man mich halt auch in der Tiefe brauchen kann, so
Das ist nicht so wie Leute, die sagen
Hey, ich kenn mich mit den Jungs aus, weil ich meine Ubuntu-VR installiert hab
Äh
Will ich hier überhaupt lang?
Anscheinend
No, we're moving away from the Gem
Go back
Was?
We're moving away from the Gem
Go back
Okay
The Maiden's Eye
An artifact of fate and doom
It's nearby
Somewhere above us
Oh!
Alter!
Donnet ist doch C, C-Sharp, C++
Ja, das ist eigentlich hauptsächlich C-Sharp
Also, du kannst noch VB machen
Allerdings VB, das macht keiner freiwillig mehr
Ähm
C++
Gibt es halt diese, diese äh
Managed Extensions oder wie das genau heißt
Das geht allerdings nur unter Windows
Also das ist was, was eigentlich keiner verwendet
.NET ist im Prinzip eigentlich C-Sharp
Das ist aber auch einfach die Sprache, die mir am meisten Bock macht
Wie gesagt, ich kann im Zweifelsfall auch was hier irgendwie in
Meinetwegen sogar in Java, wenn's sein muss
Das krieg ich wahrscheinlich auch relativ einfach hin
Auch wenn ich keinen Bock drauf hab
Wie gesagt, ich kann auch äh
Was in Groovy, Ruby, Python, JavaScript, sonst was machen, wenn's sein muss
Aber es geht halt immer darum, wo ich Bock drauf hab
Und das wäre eigentlich hauptsächlich .NET
Aha!
Oh, wat?
Findest du, man muss als Programmierer zehn Finger schreiben können?
Nö
Wozu?
Au!
Okay, mal kurz raggen
So, und der Grund, warum du keinen Zehnfinger schreiben musst, ist
Ähm
Die Zeit, wo du was schreibst
Ist in der Regel immer deutlich kürzer als die Zeit, wo du dir überlegst, wie du was machst
Ja
Klar, es gibt mal immer wieder ein paar Sachen zwischendurch, wo du sagst, da kannst du einfach
Fleißaufgaben-mäßig Sachen runtertippen, ja, okay
Aber, wenn du's ordentlich machst, Großteil der Fälle
Überlegst du mehr, als dass du tippst
Es ist genauso, wie beispielsweise die VI-Pros
Ähm
Drauf schwören, dass man
AJKL navigiert
Weil man quasi dann seine Finger immer in der Mitte hat und quasi überall gut hinkommt
Die Sache ist nun mal die
Und das konnte mir bisher auch kein VI-Pro widerlegen
Deswegen glaube ich auch einfach mal, dass man das nicht widerlegen kann, so ohne Worte
Weil es irgendwie furchtbar logisch ist, ist
Die Hälfte der Zeit
Beim entwickeln
Verbringt man weder beim, ja, weder mit Code eintippen
Noch wirklich mit nachdenken und quasi auf den Monitor gucken
Sondern im Browser irgendwelche Sachen nachschauen
Das ist die Hälfte der Zeit
Und um den Browser ordentlich zu bedienen
Musst du eine Hand an die Maus nehmen
So, und wenn du jetzt quasi danach in deinen Editor gehst
Und dort quasi nur mit der rechten Hand
HJKL navigieren kannst
Musst du quasi von der Maus komplett rüber greifen
Und dann erstmal gucken, dass du wieder auf HJKL kommst
Und dann
Fünf Minuten später
Spätestens
Wieder rüber zur Maus in den Browser
Deswegen finde ich hat das überhaupt keinen Mehrwert mehr in der heutigen Zeit
So komische Dinger zu machen
Und ich finde auch diese ganze Sache mit
Oh, eine IDE ist mir zu
Zu, zu, zu
Ploated
Ploated ist das Lieblingswort aller Leute
Die was schlecht machen wollen und nicht genau begründen können
Warum
Ja, Windows ist schlecht, warum?
Ploated
Visual Studio ist schlecht, warum?
Ähm
Keine Ahnung
Firefox ist schlecht, warum?
Ploated
Das ist
Das ist so die
Wenn du nicht weißt, warum was schlecht ist
Aber du findest es aber scheiße
Und dich fragt einer, warum ist das so
Ploated
Strange
Was, was habe ich gelootet?
Uneasy
Sword of Orbrust
Iron Damage
Krass
It's unpleasant to lift it
Those are evil, dangerous weapons, Sarah
Weapons of the Dragon Knights
They were holy fanatics
In league with the seventh dragon
When he tried to murder your father
Ach
Guck mal, da unten ist jetzt das Tor aufgegangen
Ja, man kann sich natürlich VI-Extensions installieren für den Browser
Die Sache ist die, du musst, früher oder später, musst du im Browser klicken
Das geht gar nicht anders
Selbst wenn man diese komische Link-Navigation mit der Maus verwendet
Früher oder später musst du klicken
Und sei es nur was zu copy-pasten ordentlich
Das dauert ewig mit Tastaturen
Das ist auch sowas, wo ne Maus einfach besser ist
Random Stellen in dem Text zu markieren und zu copy-pasten
Schlägt nix ne Maus
Wie gesagt, das sag ich als Linux-Fan und, und
Kommandozeilen-Fan-Pro
Moment, wie hat der Typ mich gehittet?
Wo ist mein Antidote?
Oh
Na, also Leute, wenn ihr aus der Nähe von Frankfurt kommt
Jemand braucht, der sich gut in .NET auskennt
Gute Linux-Ausgaben
Gute Linux auskennt
Gut mit Clustern auskennt
Gut mit Notverfügbarkeit auskennt
Gut mit Git auskennt
Gut mit generell irgendwelchen DevOps-Geschichten auskennt
Ordentliches Release-Management für eure Software machen kann
Ja, oder noch mehr Dinger, die ich mir ausdenke, falls ich meinen Lebenslauf schreibe
Dann sagt Bescheid
So, jetzt haben wir mal das Setout completed
Vier Tage die Woche
Geld werde ich jetzt nicht im Stream erzählen
Aber es hält sich im Rahmen
So wie eigentlich
Üblich
Also in 35k im Jahr muss, muss, muss mir keiner kommen, ne?
Das sind wir nur
No offense
Aber hatten wir alle schon
Wo geht's eigentlich hier lang?
Was haben wir denn hier?
Oh
Ich find's ja schön, dass das wenigstens so schön auffällig ist, das Loot
Was ist denn das?
Epileptische Anfälle, ich würd's gern looten
Ich darf's nicht looten
Die Seite lädt langsam
Der Sibaro möchte das noch optimieren
Alles erzählt
Aber dann muss man halt mal kurz warten
I have a bad feeling about this
Oh
Ein Sarg
Max spielt eher bestes Game
Also es ist das einzige Game seiner Art eigentlich
Max fickt auf Sponsorenzahlen immer bar
Wie Haftbefehl
Oh
Der muss gereckt werden, der Typ
Der Typ kann nix, oder?
Der kann gar nix
Was ist das für ein Boss?
Der schlechteste Boss ever
Die Inventory ist voll
Äh, das ist schlecht
Was droppen wir mal?
Ähm
Hier pinkelt irgendwas
Hört sich so an
Blub, blub, blub, blub
Ähm
Angstschwert brauchen wir nicht mehr
Den werd ich nie tragen können
Die ganzen Bogen werd ich nicht tragen können
Weil das skillen wir nicht
Ja
Was sind am nächsten erscheinende Spiele?
Muss ich mal gucken
Ich vergess das immer, was da so kommt
Ich vergess das immer
Fuck
Alter
Kann's nicht mal hüpfen?
Ähm
Müsste ich gucken
Können wir gleich mal gucken
Gucken wir gleich mal
Es ist eh
Stream ist eh fertig
Also
Also Game
Willst du mich
Der will mich rollen
Der will mich G-Baiten, ne?
G-Baited
Kackding
Gucken wir mal was für Spiele gleich rauskommen
Ja
Ich würd sagen wir speichern an der Stelle mal
Gucken wir mal was für Games rauskommen
Und morgen spielen wir es durch
Uhhh
Ok
Ähm
Sind hinter Dark Messiah nicht die heutigen Dishonored Entwickler
Das könnte tatsächlich sein
Müssen wir mal gucken
Arcane Studios
Ja ich glaub schon
Ja doch genau
Ja
Und Prey
Das neue
Also da muss man sagen
Ne
Das Entwicklerstudio hier
Das hat definitiv
Klasse Staatsmasse
Weil das kenn ich jetzt nicht
Keine Ahnung
Aber die haben das übelst gut
Das ist kein schlechter zweiter Teil
Und Dishonored ist natürlich auch nice
Ja hab ich gespielt
Aber allerdings nicht weit
Race Man
So was kommt dann so raus?
Gibt's
Hat jemand ne gute Übersicht was für Spiele demnächst rauskommen?
Ok gucken wir mal was kommt dann so als nächstes
Ok
Ähh
Forza Horizon 4 wird bestimmt gut
Interessiert mich aber nicht
Mega Man 11 ist ganz gut
Hab ich in Refuse gesehen?
Muss ganz gut sein
Odyssey ist auch ganz gut
Ähm
Playground 4 ist wie man Call of Duty erwartet
Call of Duty
Wusste gar nicht das es so ein Game geben soll
Ok
Könnte ganz gut sein
Weiß ich nicht
Ähm
Juckt mich nicht
Juckt mich
Auch nicht
Da bin ich mal gespannt drauf
Ich wusste gar nicht das es jetzt schon raus kommt
Fallout 4 ist doch noch gar nicht so alt
Ok
4 Jahre oder so
3 Jahre
Das ist für Fallout noch relativ schnell
Darksiders 3
Ganz ehrlich Leute ich glaub das wird nix
Ich würde mich ja darauf freuen auf das Game
Allerdings
Das wichtigste bei Darksiders
War eigentlich
Grafikstil
Und nachdem sie den originalen Artist nicht
Am Start haben
Der bei Darksider 1 und 2 dabei war
Glaube ich nicht das das was wird
Ich gucke sich nur mal Fury hier an
Auf dem Cover
Das sieht einfach nicht nach Darksiders aus
Guck mal was ist da für
Gibt es da irgendwelche Konzeptbilder oder
Das sieht nicht nach Darksiders
Das sieht absolut nicht nach Darksiders Grafikstil aus
Guck mal
Darksiders sah am Anfang so aus als kommt
Das ist ein Charakter der direkt aus WoW kommt
So im Endeffekt
Ja hier sowas
Das ist der Darksider Grafikstil
Guckt mal an
Guckt euch das hier an
Das hier
Das passt doch überhaupt nicht dabei
Hier gehts noch irgendwo ja
Aber das passt überhaupt nicht dabei
Deswegen bin ich skeptisch ob das was wird
Zumal ja
Die Story in Darksiders 2 schon kürze war
Wie sie auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen haben
Ja das muss parallel zum ersten Teil spielen
Anstatt eigentlich das man
Wollt ihr eigentlich nach dem ersten Teil wissen wie es weiter geht ne
Das hat man verschenkt
Weil man es wahrscheinlich selbst nicht weiß
Und ich glaube nicht das wir das jemals erfahren werden
Weil so wie es jetzt aussieht müssten die ja quasi
Darksiders 1,2,3,4 machen
Das du die Reiter durch hast
Und dann den fünften Teil mit allen drinnen wo du erfährst wie es weiter geht
Was das wird es wahrscheinlich nicht geben
Da bin ich skeptisch
Battlefield 5
Ganz ehrlich Leute wenn sich da nicht grundlegend
Grundlegend noch was geändert hat
Sehe ich
Eigentlich
Also ich weiß nicht
Nicht das es ein geiles Battlefield wird dieses Jahr
So ähm
Was haben wir noch noch
Just Cause 4
Juckt mich durch
Das ist auch so eine Gameserie
Die
Typisch in das fällt was mir eigentlich an vielen Games auf den Sack gehen
Quasi
Open World auf Teufel komm raus
Ohne das es wirklich jetzt nen
Einen Wert hat so in dem Sinn
Das ist ein Addon
Geh ich mal von aus
Weiß ich nicht bin ich nicht mit warm geworden
Sagt mir nix
Sagt mir beides nix
ETF
Tauch Simulation
Lonely Mountain Downhill
Ist das quasi die Hobbit Skateboard Variante oder wie
Rules of Madness
Irgendwie ist da nix äh
Das kommt mir bekannt vor
Das war das nicht
War das nicht das
Das Echtzeitstrategiespiel was als erstes
DirectX 12 konnte
Oder verwechsel ich das jetzt
Ich glaube ich verwechsel das
Ach nee
Das war dieses komische MMO
Wo sie sich wieder selbst übertroffen haben mit
Wie geil es wird
Oder selbst erzählt haben wie geil es wird
Und dann
Oh ein Arian
Naja ich hab meinen Stream noch nie großartig angekündigt
Ich hab heute zum ersten mal auf Youtube gepostet
Aber ich finde das so auch besser
Muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen
Ähm
Weil das ja eines der Gründe ist
Die mein Youtube auf den Sack geht
So alles drum herum
Deswegen finde ich es viel besser
Ich kenne die Leute hier
Ja
Ich hab hier auch keine Probleme
Immer 7 Stunden irgendwas zu spielen
Da regt mich nix auf
Ähm
Also irgendwie kommt da nicht wirklich was oder
Facecam gibt es wenn ich 1 Million Abos auf Youtube hab
Also nie
Haha
Metro bin ich mal gespannt drauf
Ich muss übrigens noch
Oh ja Metro ist auch noch eine Reihe
Die müssen wir hier Onstream
Weil ich hab nur den ersten Teil gespielt
Und ich hab auch gehört die anderen sind nicht so geil
Also den hier den da
Der war nice
Was haben wir denn hier sonst noch so
Juckt mich alles nicht
Oh das ist das
Das ist das Bubkampf Spiel oder
Das ist irgendwie verbuggt mein Browser
Ist das nicht das Bubkampf Spiel
Ja
Anthem da bin ich auch mal gespannt drauf
Aber ich sag es euch jetzt schon
Das wird wieder so ein Game
Wo alle denken am Anfang
Oh das hat Potential
Und dann kommt es raus
Und man stellt fest das hinter der
Fassade nix ist
Ich sag es euch jetzt schon
Ich würde mir ja wünschen
Das ich mit solchen Sachen öfters falsch liege
Ja
Aber ich muss sagen so vieles
Was ich mir so für mich immer überlegt habe
In den letzten Jahren in dieser Richtung
Das ist dann auch so geworden
Und BioWare hat mal so geile Dinger gemacht
Das letzte richtig gute von ihnen
Dürfte eigentlich Dragon Age gewesen sein
Ne Mass Effect
Warte mal
Nicht dass ich das durcheinander bringe
Mass Effect
Was war zuerst Mass Effect oder Dragon Age
Boah ist das schon so alt
Alter ist das von
Ne 2000 2000
2009 2007 ok
Dann war es Dragon Age
Das letzte gescheite von ihnen
Dragon Age
Ja
Also das was als letztes gekommen ist
Danach hatten die nicht mehr so viel oder
So viel gutes
Top Top
Weiß gar nicht was es ist
Top Top Top
Hab ich nicht gespielt
Bei Never Never Winter Nights war nie so mein Fall
Muss ich sagen
Das war zu
Nicht wirklich Sandbox zu zu zu
Sandbox keine Ahnung
Ähm
Naja
Nice
Ich weiß nicht
Ich bin kein Fan von Mass Effect außer dem ersten
Dragon Age Origins war sehr nice
Dragon Age 2 schon nicht mehr so
Zu den Star Wars Games kann ich nicht sagen
Den Rest kannst du vergessen
Nutzt du noch deine Switch sehr selten
Es gibt immer noch kein Browser für die Switch oder
So was kommt denn sonst noch so raus
Metro ja wie gesagt da bin ich gespannt raus
Crackdown 3
Sollte das nicht schon gefühlt irgendwie
Ich habe noch ein T-Shirt
Crackdown 3
Fällt mir gerade ein
Von der Gamescom
2015 oder so
Und wisst ihr was ich auch noch für ein T-Shirt habe
Wahrscheinlich
Ultra Rare
Ich habe noch ein
Scale kennt das noch jemand
Scale Bound T-Shirt
Das ist das was sie eingestellt haben
Kurz bevor es fertig war
Devil May Cry juckt mich nicht
Division 2
Ist das
Ist Division 2 nicht schon längst raus
Oder bin ich das
Bringe ich das gerade durcheinander
Anscheinend nicht
Der Destiny 2
Ja stimmt
Lull
Das ist was von Felix
Geht da ab drauf
Battalion 1944
Da bin ich mal gespannt ob sie die Kurve kriegen
Plasphemos
Sagt mir nix
Pixel
Wie es ganz nett aussieht
Iron Man
Ne Ne Ne Ne Ion
Ne
Ion
Hat mit Iron Man nichts zu tun
Sagt mir nix
Ist das nicht so eine Netflix Serie
Ah ok doch
Total War juckt mich nicht
Sea of Solitude
Sea of Solitude ist das Sony
Das Sony Sea of Thieves Verschnitt
Der wahrscheinlich auch nix wird
Oder bring ich das
Ne Ne Ne Bounce war das Bounce war das Sony
Da blickt
Das ist
Ja
Ah Alter ich blick da nicht mehr durch
Es ist so viel
So viel
Einheitliches
Bloß von anderen Leuten immer
Da kannst du überhaupt nicht mehr durchblicken
Wolfenstein
Oh so ein Wolfenstein
Find ich Nice
Das Letzte fand ich echt gut
Die Siedler
divulge
Ach wollen sie das erste Mal remaken
Ja gut
Warum nicht
Ist das noch Blue Byte
Gibt es die überhaupt noch
Ähhh
Hallo
Ich würde gerne
Ich würde gerne eine Suche öffnen.
Browser, Steuerung, F.
Ah, ich sehe es bloß nicht.
Okay, von Blue Byte keine Erwähnung mehr.
Also, sag mal, kann das irgendwie sein, dass es 2019 ziemlich wenig Zeug gibt, was da so ansteht?
Skull & Bones ist Ubisoft, ich blicke da an.
Wir sagen die meisten Games irgendwas, aber die Zuordnung fällt mir mittlerweile so schwer.
Vor allem, weil du oftmals quasi drei ziemlich ähnliche Games hast, halt von der Konkurrenz immer so.
Es ist nicht wenig, nur wenig, was dich interessiert.
Ja, das kommt aber aus Gleiche raus.
Für mich.
Ich meine, 2018 war, also im Nachhinein betrachtet, gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Also, meine persönliche Überraschung ist ja tatsächlich Pathfinder gewesen.
Das hatte ich überhaupt nicht auf dem Radar, dass das rauskommt.
Und dann war das auf einmal da und dann war das ein richtig nices Game.
Mal gucken, was das jetzt mittlerweile für Bewertungen hat.
Mixt, immer noch.
Warum regen sich die Leute immer noch auf, dass es zu schwer ist?
Äh, ihr möge laden.
Laden, Blitz.
Okay, äh, wie kann man das sortieren nach...
Ach, da läuft da noch irgendwas im Hintergrund, aber warum ist mein Rechter so lahmkörnerisch?
Nö.
Nix da, außer zig Chrome-Browsers von Steam.
Crash oft, mein Game ist ohne Scheiß...
Ich kann mich nicht dran erinnern, dass es schon einmal gecrashed ist.
Also, Pathfinder crasht wenig, das hat ein paar Bugs, ja, das ist...
Aber crashen tut's nicht.
Hard as hell.
Naja.
Das sind die Leute, die quasi einmal irgendwo hinlaufen wollen und alles bashen.
Die meisten Leute und vor allem Leute, die jetzt halt, ähm...
Quasi recht...
Neu sind, so in diesem Genre auch, die die Spiele von früher nicht kennen,
die verkraften das nicht mehr, wenn man in ein Gebiet kommt, wo man nicht alles wegownen kann.
Also sprich, wenn es ein Gebiet gibt, sag mal mal ein Low-Level-Gebiet,
wo du irgendwie die Goblin-Horde wegschnetzelst, plus in der Höhle ist halt ein Drache oder sowas, ja,
dann verkraften die das nicht, dass die quasi erst nach 40 Stunden Spiel wieder zurückkommen können in das Gebiet
und dann den Drache bashen.
Das kriegen die nicht, äh, das ist für die persönlicher Defeat, quasi.
Die sind dann...
Die uninstallen dann.
Wirst du dir das neue Pokémon kaufen?
Nee, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Encounter-Design is terrible.
Find ich gar nicht...
Ich kann ohne Scheiß bei dem Game, kann ich die negativen Bewertungen zum größten Teil nicht nachvollziehen.
Ich kann nur die Bewertungen nachvollziehen, die sich über, ähm, Bugs aufregen,
ja, okay, aber über diese ganze Balancing-Geschichte, wenn man sich ein bisschen Mühe gibt
und eine ordentliche Party zusammenstellt, ist das überhaupt gar kein Problem, das Game.
Und ich meine, ich spiele es extra auch schwer, dass es auch ein bisschen knackig ist, ja.
Das Game hat... wäre es ein bisschen... würde da noch ein bisschen was reinfließen, ja,
ein bisschen... noch ein bisschen die Begleiter-Quests noch ein bisschen bessern,
noch ein bisschen... noch ein bisschen die Begleiter-Quests noch ein bisschen bessern,
noch... noch alles ein bisschen ausgefeilter, sagen wir mal, noch ein halbes Jahr länger, ja,
und noch ein paar... noch ein bisschen Feinschiff, das hätte echt so Klassiker-Potenzial, das Game.
Reload-Simulator.
Ladezeiten hat das Game wirklich ein bisschen viele.
Ja, da hast du deine Quests nicht gemacht.
Die Leute sind so blöd!
Du kriegst sogar eine Quest, wo da steht, wenn du sie nicht machst,
hast du verloren.
Allerdings hast du irgendwie 360 Tage Ingame-Zeit dafür,
und das ist wirklich nicht schwer.
Und ich muss auch... ich finde auch die... die Rest- und Sleep-Mechanik finde ich richtig cool gemacht.
Das ist halt mal ein bisschen was mit Tiefe.
Du musst jemand abstellen, der das Lager bewacht,
du musst jemand abstellen, der kocht,
du musst jemand abstellen, der das Lager tarnt,
jemand abstellen, der Leute heilt.
Das machst du einmal, dann klickst du einfach auf Rest.
Ist ja nicht so, dass du das jedes Mal machen musst.
Ach, keine Ahnung, ich verstehe die...
Also, ich kann ja bei den meisten Games die negativen Reviews oftmals nachvollziehen,
allerdings...
hier nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Äh...
City...
Ich hoffe, ich spreche das richtig aus.
Ähm...
Das mache ich aber auch.
Und das ist tatsächlich ein Fail in dem Design,
wo man sieht, dass man nicht einfach Pen-and-Paper-Regeln übernehmen kann in ein Spiel.
Ja, also sprich, wenn du jetzt mit irgendwelchen Leuten zusammensitzt,
da kannst du nicht einfach sagen,
äh...
Game Master ist reloaded.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Da musst du halt damit leben.
Ja, und dann ist halt auch kacke, wenn du...
das wichtige Item nicht kriegst, wobei halt dein Game Master dafür sorgen wird,
dass du es dann doch irgendwie...
Na, weil der will ja, dass du progressen kannst im Endeffekt.
Wenn es halt nicht einer ist, der gegen die Leute spielt.
Aber das wird ja meistens nicht der Fall sein.
Und...
In Spielen ist es halt einfach so,
dadurch, dass du erstens keinen Game Master hast,
in dem Sinne, dass du das ein bisschen anpassen kannst,
sodass es halt zur Kampagne passt,
ähm...
und du reloaden kannst, führt das eben dazu,
dass die Leute so oft wie loaden, wie sie müssen,
um die Kiste zu knacken.
Deswegen musst du einfach unendlich retry einbauen.
Das ist das Einfachste.
Du machst das...
Du musst unendlich retry einbauen,
allerdings nicht mit gar so sehr großer Varianz im Würfeln,
sondern musst einfach sagen,
okay, du kannst diese Kiste jetzt nicht knacken,
weil du hast nicht genug Skill.
Und dann musst du einfach skillen.
Dann musst halt kein Lucky wurfen,
sondern du musst halt wirklich einfach skillen.
Das ist wieder sowas,
was du halt einfach nicht von Pen & Paper übernehmen kannst ordentlich.
Ja, das sind so ein paar Sachen, die sind nicht schön,
aber das rechtfertigt keine Negativbewertung in dem Sinne.
Ja.
Sag mal, kann das sein?
Kann das sein, dass du sogar Mod-Budden bist?
Ich bilde mir ein, ich habe den Namen mal gesehen da irgendwo.
Ich habe gerade bei Steam eine Hardware-Umfrage gemacht.
Ist AMD wirklich so am Abnibbeln?
GPU hat AMD...
Naja, die hatten ja jahrelang nichts.
Die hatten ja jahrelang nichts.
Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die...
Wenn du das vor Ryzen gemacht hättest,
diese Statistik,
dass dann AMD wahrscheinlich bei 5% gewesen wäre
und jetzt nach Ryzen sind es halt schon mal bei 15%.
Also so ungefähr.
Würde mich nicht wundern.
Ich könnte mir allerdings vorstellen,
wenn AMD jetzt so weitermacht,
dass die tatsächlich wieder ordentlich aufholen werden.
Oh nee.
Peeperhands, ja.
Ja, ähm...
Gut, äh...
So gewisse...
Die Leute wollen halt einfach auch gewisse Emails haben
und wenn es die da natürlich noch channelpersonalisiert gibt,
natürlich noch mal cool.
Dann darfst du jetzt bei mir moderieren.
Wenn du schon nicht mal bei Dan moderieren darfst.
Das Katzenbild in deinem Profil hat den Ausschlag dazu gegeben.
Ja, man muss sich da schon die richtigen Leute für rausholen.
Ja, was gibt's...
Genau, eine Sache wollte ich noch über Kingmaker loswerden.
Also wer es noch nicht gekauft hat
und auf Oldschool klassische RPGs steht,
sollte sich das wirklich kaufen.
Damit kann man eigentlich nichts falsch machen.
Wieso?
Es sind doch schon ganz viele andere Bots auch da.
Ähm...
Ja.
Also wenn ich mich entscheiden müsste zwischen Pillars 2
und Pathfinder.
Auf jeden Fall Pathfinder.
Pillars 2 war nicht mein Fall.
Und Original Sin 2 kann man nicht so wirklich damit vergleichen,
weil es ein...
Erstens weil es ein eigenes Regelwerk ist
und rundenbasiert.
Also komplett rundenbasiert.
So.
Ähm...
Ich hoffe euch hat's gefallen.
Ich muss jetzt pennen.
Ich muss morgen nämlich wieder arbeiten gehen.
Ich werde jetzt erstmal meinen YouTube Post löschen.
Ich find's cool.
Die meisten Leute freuen sich,
dass ich's gepostet hab auf YouTube.
Sehr, sehr nice.
Okay Leute, ihr wisst was das heißt.
Die sieht ein bisschen aus wie meine hier.
Schwarz-Weiß.
Bisschen.
Wisst ihr eigentlich...
Hab ich euch eigentlich schon erzählt wie meine Katze heißt?
Weil, wie gesagt, ich hab die ja aus dem Tierheim
und den Namen hab ich mir nicht ausgedacht.
Also ihr wisst ja, ich nenn meine Katze immer eigentlich nur Katze,
aber die hat einen Namen.
Ja.
Und einen Namen, den ich meiner Katze im Leben nicht gegeben hätte.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das schon mal erzählt hab.
Ja, nachdem keiner sagt, ich hab's schon mal erzählt,
kann ich's noch mal erzählen.
Die Katze heißt...
Haltet euch fest.
Barbie.
Weil die Oma...
Ich vermute mal irgendeine Oma, die sie vorher hatte,
der Meinung war, sie heißt Barbie.
Ich würde im Leben meine Katze nicht Barbie nennen.
So.
Leute.
Seid ihr noch da?
Oder ist mein Chat kaputt?
Ich glaub, mein Chat ist kaputt.
Ich seh nix.
Guck mal, ob mein OBS-Chat geht.
Geht auch nicht.
Hm.
Ich würd fast sagen, der Chat ist kaputt.
Sonst hätte in der Zwischenzeit wahrscheinlich schon irgendjemand was geschrieben.
Okay, Leute.
Ähm.
Ich hoffe, euch hat's gefallen.
Ich glaub, der Chat ist kaputt.
Machen wir jetzt Schluss.
Ähm.
Morgen geht's weiter.
Zweite Runde.
Macht's gut.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
C U.
Ja, Twitch hat echt grad Probleme.
Nicht reloaden, sonst ist es gleich kaputt.
Bis dann.